ou en ligne vivez comprenez en direct
les parties des meilleurs joueurs de la
planète avec les commentaires en
français de nos experts notre moteur
d'analyse l'explorateur d'ouverture et
les tables bases retrouvez toutes les
infos essentielles comme le programme
les horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats des comptes-rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chains.com/avent aussi bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
et bonjour à tous salut à toi Antoine
j'espère que vous allez tous très très
bien bienvenue sur le stream
salut stuff salut tout le monde
bienvenue pour cette troisième journée
du norwatch on va encore se régaler ça
fait deux jours qu'on voit des parties
de dingue et ça devrait pas changer
aujourd'hui ouais alors aujourd'hui on a
encore un beau plateau Antoine
je vais vous les montrer avec ici notre
notre scène
ronde on a Hikaru d'un Cameron avec les
Blancs contre Magnus Carlson champion du
monde prononce garden
OK
pas plus pas moins Carlsen
salut que je nourrice ensuite il y aura
nous dire Beck à 12 octobre contre allez
resa firuggia voilà de deux gamins de 19
ans qui sont déjà plus fort que que la
plupart des gens aux échecs dans le
monde
et qui vont sûrement de faire une belle
game là je parierai de nul nul
c'est compliqué j'ai pas envie de parler
contre le français mais il est quand
même enfin moi je le trouve sacrément
sacrément fort je parlais à bout juste
pour essayer de pas être dans enfin dans
ton sens quoi
changer un peu les résultats
après on a Fabiano Caruana Contrarian
tari alors là c'est le leader du tournoi
contre le dernier pour moi il y a aucun
doute Fabiano va l'emporter
ok bah écoute moi je vais mettre nul ah
tu peux absolument pas aller contre moi
d'accord
charia m'aveziah contre Gou Kech ça ça
va être une des parties à mon avis les
plus disputés de la journée je vais
parier nulle par répétition OK et ben
écoute moi je vais je vais suivre comme
d'hab mon petit poulain
et on va donner victoire à thé noir à
vous cash ça serait beau ça serait beau
pareil même pas sur ce gris
alors on va vous montrer un petit peu
les parties qui viennent de commencer
juste à l'instant
alors la première partie ici que vous
voyez à l'écran on a
ikaro lycamoa avec les Blancs contre
Magnus Carlsen donc c'est une Espagnole
sans grande surprise alors que dans le
chat il y a que je Norris il y a Dav ça
met des pièces sur Abdou ça te refais
qui est sur Youtube donc bonjour à tous
En tout cas n'hésitez pas pour ceux qui
sont ceux qui sont YouTube là
aujourd'hui je vais dire le chat
généralement c'est un on oublie un petit
peu de là où le chat ici
vous savez que les stats je crois qu'on
a 29% seulement des gens qui nous
regardent sur Youtube qui qui sont
abonnés à la chaîne 29% des gens
abonnez-vous sont abonnés donc ça vous
coûte rien c'est un petit clic sur
abonné vous serez au courant de tout ce
qui se passe
tous les événements toutes les vidéos
tous les shorts tous les trucs qui vous
pouvez avoir un petit clic suffit donc
ceux qui sont sur Youtube n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner en tout cas c'est gratuit
et nous ça nous soutient aussi et pour
ceux qui sont montés sur cheesecom par
sur twitch n'hésitez pas aussi à nous
follow c'est vous serez averti de tous
les strings tous les trucs en direct
donc n'hésitez pas en tout cas à nous
suivre et puis et puis voilà donc
bienvenue à tous j'espère que vous serez
nombreux aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de
stream en même temps aujourd'hui j'ai vu
qu'il y avait aussi la le Top 16 qui
avait commencé
et aujourd'hui comme ça c'est c'est un
super tournoi que je bah que moi j'adore
enfin j'ai participé une fois dans ma
vie d'ailleurs c'est même pas en top 7
entre 12 que j'ai joué
et là mon club
est remontant cette année donc on
pourrait se voir on pourrait y voir la
saison prochaine vous allez me voir
je crois
a priori et c'est cool en plus cette
année en Top 16 il va y avoir du fin
d'année prochaine il va y avoir du monde
du monde vous connaissez en terme de de
cheesecom français etc déjà les
habitudes
mvl il a sûrement y être Etienne bac pro
par son Mariet j'ai le Moussa
aussi
Laurent pressiner il sera aussi Kevin
thérieux il sera aussi donc tous ces
joueurs là donc j'oublie aussi Mathieu
cornette les Sébastien Mazet etc
évidemment seront là et en plus de ces
joueurs qui sont à chaque année et bien
vous aurez souffre vous aurez l'honneur
de voir et le plaisir aussi mais aussi
vous pourrez voir aussi vous pourrez
suivre aussi peut-être les un petit peu
les
d'autres comment dire
staff de cette com avec Samy et Nathan
qui font partie du même club qui qui est
monté cette année c'est vrai donc
beaucoup beaucoup de gens connus l'année
prochaine et est-ce que
Magnus viendrait pas d'envoyer un Gambie
Marshall totalement accepté par les
carreau ouais donc en bi Marshall c'est
ce Gambie regarde bien ces trois D5 donc
c'est souvent on peut penser que c'est
un coin naturel parce que après eux
prendre des 5 cavaler prendre en perles
pion E5 mais c'est une ligne qui a été
enfin c'est un Gambie et peut-être même
un des seuls Gambie qui est encore
jouable de nos jours
et très très souvent comme Samy dans le
chat nous nous propose et ben on va
avoir une turbo de haut alors en fait il
y a plein de perpétuelles plein de trucs
qui arrivent donc voilà
Magnus peut avoir des idées dans la
Marshall mais normalement
[Musique]
voilà quoi ah tu penses que ça va
envoyer une ligne théorique de
la maison ils ont joué 15 coups en 3
minutes
ouais ça récite pour l'instant ça récite
en fait
et
ce qu'on aurait pu parier c'est sur les
nuls qu'on a parié moi j'ai parié sur la
nul tu vois sur la nul que j'ai
pesé
que j'ai crédit entre carreaux cartonne
j'aurais pu aussi envoyer en plus un
Armageddon un score Armageddon ah oui ce
que je vais faire
ma petite oui je suis d'accord avec toi
là dessus mais attention on y est pas à
l'armée il aurait pas préparé une petite
idée sur le Marshall ben je connais pas
assez la théorie du Marshall mais
peut-être la c'est les noirs qui
rentrent dans le Marshall les blancs
aussi ils auraient pu avec D3 empêché
alors généralement à la place de ces
trois on peut faire Détroit c'est un peu
l'anti Marshall qui empêche toutes les
idées de de dessin donc soit en V3 on
peut le jouer et là ça n'a pas été joué
donc
Hikaru le laisse
Magnus normalement sur le marché
je peux quand même pas jouer pour plus
que la nul si Hikaru décide de ne pas
gagner
il y a plein de ventes de nuls sont
assez terribles moi je là je suis pas un
spécialiste mais ça sert à rien quoi là
on voit que les noirs
et sur case blanche il y a pas mal de
jeux dans les clés blancs aucune pièce
ici mais on va plus en plus mais c'est
vraiment hyper théorique qui a été joué
des milliers et des milliers de fois et
moi je pense que ça va vraiment faire
nul très très rapidement avec une une
répétition donc Magnus elle est noir
donc c'est pour ça qu'avec les Noirs
Magnus noir contre
Naka bah écoute une nulle c'est quand
même un résultat assez fort
Naka blanc noir il est content je pense
faire une petite recherche pour voir si
éventuellement parce que moi j'y crois
encore ce que fait éventuellement si
quelqu'un nous avait préparé une petite
nouveauté on va regarder pour l'instant
effectivement on est dans le terrain
très connus et très anulants comme nous
le faisait remarquer Sami effectivement
donc tout revit donc on va sûrement
échanger
je connais pas la suite du tout où j'ai
4 et sur dame G2 on peut imaginer un
damage 5 pour essayer de faire faux F3
effectivement ça va être compliqué de
trouver de trouver une filouterie dans
cette position qui a été
probablement
mais je vois pas la suite
H3
c'est une variante qui a déjà été jouée
12 fois à très haut niveau et que des
nuls effectivement
ah ok j'ai compris bon l'idée en fait
c'est que on n'a pas peur du cavalier en
prise parce qu'après option prend bien
si tu manges mon cavalier je remange et
je me rendslais ici et ça va faire nul
voilà bon
ils auront tenu quand même
10 minutes
et je pense que ce sera la dernière fois
qu'on va voir leur partie parce qu'il
doit y avoir forcément plus intéressant
ailleurs qu'est-ce que tu en penses
on ira voir après l'Armageddon mais
une partie un peu de repos pour ce genre
là qui ont décidé de faire en prise
prise et chaque échec et ça va faire nul
on a une semi slave on a une semi slave
chez elle et résa peut-être qu'on
pourrait aller voir ça on va aller voir
ça
va se terminer dans les autres qui
viennent
ok ok alors attends
c'est fini et en plus je suis
je suis assez
[Musique]
largement dans les temps ça fait appel
une minute que tu as dit ça ok
ça va perpétuer comme ça je pense
tout le 4 F3 et voilà on a trouvé la nul
et ça va se serrer la louche
pour être large c'est 15 ça me
paraissait long
et est-ce qu'on va arriver au moins 12
quand même
bon
j'ai une petite anecdote à ce sujet une
fois j'avais un pote qui venait voir un
tournoi d'échec auquel je participais et
il y avait jamais vu de tournoi d'échec
de sa vie et je lui conseille d'aller
voir la partie entre deux mètres
internationaux c'était je dis bah c'est
impressionnant de voir des maîtres
jouets va voir eux je peux peut-être les
citer d'ailleurs c'était des Français et
c'était Jean-Baptiste Mulon et Victor
Stephan et je lui dis bah va voir bah
voilà la table 1 il y a des il y a des
forts joueurs quoi et ils ont fait nul
en
bon 4 minutes il était complètement déçu
quoi il a rien compris à ce qui s'est
passé en fait et c'est vrai que pour un
pour un novice là parce que viennent
faire Nakamura et carlset bah c'est un
peu bizarre ils sont pas battus
je pense qu'en fait ils se sont parlé
sur mon la veille
ils ont conclu d'un match nulle la
veille probable je pense pas je pense
pas qu'ils ont besoin de faire ça je
pense qu'ils peuvent le faire sans
parler ça
j'ai vu dans la règlement il fallait pas
prendre
et les enfers
évidemment à des génies et c'est même
pas ironique
ok donc c'est parti elle est terminée on
aura un magasin prochainement
ok
je les aurais tout là excuse-moi
sur les autres échiquiers aujourd'hui on
a uniquement des parties du pion de D4
ok donc semi slave chez Ali résa c'est
assez dense
on voit un peu depuis le début si vous
voulez
mesdames voilà les idées de jouer 4
et généralement sur 4 très souvent les
Noirs répondent alors ça dépend hein
mais ici bon si je fais prise ici
malheureusement j'ai pas le temps de le
faire il y a le 5 qui va arriver oups
mais des fois il y a une idée de faire
ça ça et ça casser un petit peu les
cases noires
mais du coup sur le castre et sûrement
les noirs pour répondre pas la prise ici
dans le 5 avec après plus tard
par exemple
alors idée de rupture au noir leur idée
de rupture c'est toujours c'est simple
dans ce genre de structure j'imagine
ou le noir arrive pas je sais 5 et c'est
blanc qui vont jouer
il va offrir la case des 5 au noir et
enfermé le fou baisser les idées qui
sont assez thématiques mais je vais
amorce les cinq ça arrive
ouais si les blancs font ça ils jouent
contre les deux fois de verse en fait
parce que même le footcas noir se
retrouvait
on notera
on en parlait hier à quelqu'un qui
débutait aux échecs qui nous demandait
comment progresser un peu bah regarde ce
qu'on fait les deux joueurs là ils ont
développé toutes leurs pièces mineures
ils ont Rocket ils ont ils occupent
chacun un peu le centre il se battent
pour le centre pour l'instant ils sont
chacun de leur côté de l'échiquier il
respecte tous les principes là c'est
vraiment une ouverture très principale
ça risque de changer très vite au centre
si tu fais ça un magasin
[Musique]
sur slack
18 minutes ok donc à 33 exactement
ils sont pris une petite journée de
repos là Magnus et Karu en 17
complètement
ils vont juste se faire un blitz tout à
l'heure j'espère que ça va être animé le
Blitz alors tu mets tes sous sur Magnus
moi aussi
si dans le chat de quelqu'un croit en
Hikaru qu'il le dise maintenant où se
tais à jamais bien sûr
donc
première réflexion pour ça fait 5
minutes qu'il réfléchit là il a Blitz
tous les coups jusque là et le tour 8 de
resa semble lui poser une première
question alors du coup évident moi j'en
vois c'est des coûts qu'on pourrait
jouer en blitz par exemple tours
et effectivement on peut déjà envisager
peut-être cette rupture E4 peut-être
qu'il y pense déjà mais en fait les
Noirs
avant après faut faire attention parce
que la rupture 5 elle est pas forcément
si claire parce que il y aurait la
possibilité pour manger là et manger là
ça crée un peu passé un pion isolé au
noir par exemple
un truc comme ça
ça crée un pion isolé au noir
mais après souvent dans cette position
quand alors je disais que c'est un truc
du style je crois on peut avoir des
pensées car celui de 5
aussi à cette thématique
et il y a eu trois dents
qui met la tour en vis-à-vis sur la dame
donc voilà par rapport à l'idée E5 qui
maintenant je suis écoute je suis
directement en face de la dame et sur le
plan
alors c'est quoi le l'idée profonde de
mettre la tour a en D1 là ça serait pas
mieux de mettre la tour en C1 puisque
c'est c'est une colonne qui va s'ouvrir
aussi et la tour F est très bien pour
aller en D alors elle va s'ouvrir si je
le veux
moi qui vais manger peut-être après
ici par exemple après la prise de
partout
essayer de poser mon cavalier pour le C5
j'ai aussi les tours en e1d1 en fait
c'est les deux tours centrales
que tu viens mettre en place
[Musique]
et donc elle est Raisa qui qui a enlevé
sa dame tout de suite du vis-à-vis en la
mettant E7 et maintenant c'est Tour
Eiffel qui est joué par le
parlouzbeck
est-ce qu'on va faire on va passer un
petit tour si tu veux sur car
vana
tari ça joue un gambidam refusé par
exemple d'échange
en fait on a transposé un peu mais il me
semble que on revient dans le gambidam
refusé comme ceci après des cinq
G7 OK
[Musique]
ok
ce serait pas la fameuse attaque de
minorité pour les blancs là alors les
blancs vont jouer donc
soit dans le chat qui n'ont jamais
entendu ça ou qu'ils savent pas ce que
c'est simplement c'est quand je pousse
des pions moi il a une j'ai deux pions
contre ce côté trois pions
avec deux pions trois ponts là haut on
part en petit rock si je fais des trucs
assez logique ça tourne pour GB4 et B5
et elle est en fait bouffer en C6 et sur
la présence de 6 et ben on aurait des
colonnes ouvertes et je peux aussi ce
qui serait un pion arriéré que je
pourrais un jour donc vraiment je vais
essayer de faire des coups un peu bateau
juste pour voir d'accord
et essayer d'avoir une position de ce
type là je vais faire encore un peu
bizarre on a juste pour illustrer
FC1 et on va taper sur le plan C6 avec
cavalier 5 cavalier 5 etc c'est un peu
les idées sur le pion là-haut l'objectif
c'est de créer une faiblesse et après
d'empiler toutes ses forces dessus et ça
peut gagner un pion un jour après il y a
plein de façons de jouer contre un pion
qui paraît qui peut paraître bizarre
qui peut aussi arriver je peux avoir un
cavalier très fort ici et si tu fais
instinct ton pur mais quatre il est pas
forcément
si
[Musique]
solide tu vois il peut se faire attaquer
encore une fois
en B6 C4
ça peut faiblesse contre faiblesse dans
ce cas-là mais pour l'instant Fabiano
lui il est complètement dans sa prépa il
a pas réfléchi du tout en revanche
Ariane tari il a déjà réfléchi près de
20 minutes dans cette position il veut
absolument pas se retrouver avec une
poubelle dans l'ouverture parce qu'il
sait contre Fabi après ça sera trop
compliqué donc le coût évident là dans
cette pause on pourrait dire bah on
pourrait juste OK et effectivement je
pense que ok doit pas être mauvais mais
il veut d'abord comprendre tous les
tenants et les aboutissants est-ce que
Caval BD7 avant est meilleur enfin il
réfléchit à tout ça je pense
et c'était pas mal
alors souvent dans ces positions parce
qu'en fait je connais une position si tu
veux une sorte de
semis
avec les noirs et il est assez profonde
pour jouer à psy bon l'aspect milieu de
changer les mauvais fous mais il y a
aussi l'idée de faire cavalier 7 pour
aller en F8 et en soutenir en E6 et
le fou ici et des fois je peux revenir
avec cavalier en G7 et F5 pour contrôler
toutes ces cases là centrales donc c'est
un petit peu long mais c'est les idées
qui existent dans ces positions donc
peut-être qu'il est en train de penser
est-ce que tu rock ou est-ce que je veux
d'abord faire
il y a plusieurs plusieurs choix c'est
que nous ne sont pas la position on a
envie de rocker sans réfléchir
des
coups comme ça qui sont plus
des petites subtilités tout simplement
donc pour l'instant écoute normal pas
encore le feu sur le chéquier qu'on a pu
voir ailleurs entre Abdou et
et Paris là ça se calme c'est très calme
sur tous les échiquiers d'ailleurs en
fait parce que il y a une Anglaise une
anglaise des quatre cavales chez chez ma
média Rohff et gokesh
ou pas mal de matériels pourraient
s'échanger au centre dans les prochains
coups
bonjour à toi j'espère que tu es abonné
abonnez
c'est gratuit les gars c'est gratuit
vous êtes à chaque fois vous êtes averti
dès qu'il y a la moindre chose
un stream une vidéo un short n'importe
quoi vous serez averti et c'est gratuit
alors
ça c'est les positions qui sont assez
connues
F3 donc c'est très connu très solide moi
je connais pas mais c'est quand même
connu et là je ne connais pas non plus
bon après c'est des positions
je ne la connais pas
et alors on voit qu'il y a une petite
pression des blancs
un fou une dame tout le monde qui tape
sur le panason mais il y a aussi
attention un vis-à-vis un clouage sur
Caval S3
il y a un clouage sur cette tension
entre le pion C4 et le pion D5 personne
ne peut prendre les Noirs passent ils
perdraient la dame les blancs parce
qu'il perdrait le cavalier c'est ça
c'est bien donc Google qui a dépensé 5
minutes pour les 11 premiers coups donc
on peut imaginer que lui il est encore
dans la théorie il sait ce qu'il fait il
est pas perdu
un peu plus ma mec a déjà utilisé plus
d'un quart d'heure il réfléchit plus
enfin ici comme ce qu'il fait il est pas
totalement
parce que j'imagine que ces analyses
sont assez dites et
j'aurais bien dit que dans cette pose
des Français 4 est une menace quand même
positionnelle
ce qu'il faut pas réagir tout de suite
maintenant à cette tension pour les
blancs c'est ma positionnel mais aussi
matériel oui c'est aussi un pion c'est
sûr on peut prendre un pion
quand même quand on a pas développé le
foot casse blanche c'est sûr que là j'ai
un problème de ce côté là et pour C1 et
un cavalier bouge quelque part peut
avoir du vieux c'est pas si simple c'est
sûr que niveau développement les blancs
sont devant et que c'est pas si facile
d'aller faire valoir tout ça mais
à la pose qui pense qu'il peut aller
manger le pion il peut y aller mais
après
cavale B5 déjà pour lui poser une
question je dirais attends tadam en C7
elle est un peu trop bien placée
mais là ailleurs donc il va la mettre
sans doute en B6 et ensuite
développement fou B2 gratuit peut-être
justement je voulais venir ici mais je
sais pas si c'est un bon coup
des deux pour vous ces trois dans ce cas
là maintenant je mange
tous ces trois à terre
dans ce cas là et en plus il y a une
menace de
ouais il y a 6 qui arrive là pour les
Noirs tout de suite c'était un peu
embêtant en fait moi j'ai comme ça
bon c'est un peu très vite s'activer en
tout cas ça peut être chaud parce que si
on joue un truc de ce style là il est
possible que Google gagne un peu mais il
a joué Caval le V5
j'ai envie de dire que si c'est pour me
ramener la dame en B8
j'ai envie de dire bon c'était bizarre
c'est mieux de faire un truc avec un
tempo donc dame 5 ça doit être ça doit
forcément être mieux en fait
concrètement là si jamais je fais ça et
que tu fais par exemple je passe à
ben j'ai l'impression que les blancs
font quand même pas mal quoi j'ai pas de
pions de moi et j'ai une position
qu'elle me prédynamique
j'imagine que contre dynamisme des
blancs
doit être le coup ici le coup critique
quoi qui force fou des deux ou peut-être
on peut faire tourner pour mettre le
foot directement en B2 je vais quand
même faire ça en fait
oui c'est sûr ouais et on est obligé de
reprendre sinon on perd le cavalier B5
important ah oui non il y a pas
d'intermédiaire
sur
le placement d'armes là j'ai quand même
créer un premier isolé 4K
en fait à son problème là tu vois il y a
quand même un problème sur le
en revanche c'est aussi un problème sur
le pont c'est cap
et
sera assise cavale des quatre c'est un
vrai problème pratique à régler pour les
noirs
[Musique]
je vais essayer de jouer sur l'activité
je vais quand même récupérer le B7
assez rapidement
il est pas mal je pense
et tout reprend je gagne un tempo sur
ton ouf
ah non c'est vrai que les Noirs les
Noirs en fait on doit on doit être un
peu en train de chipoter sur une
position qui est quasiment égale
j'imagine non je pense qu'il faut garder
la pression
[Musique]
je pense qu'il faut continuer
il empêche le fou c'est 8 de se
développer un peu c'est pour ça qu'il
est fort la menace est plus forte que
l'exécutions
en tout cas
salut Mick salut Mick du 44 le 44 dans
mon cœur
donc parti ouais on peut aller voir
maintenant je vous ai pas mis la caméra
de de me mettre boukh ils sont là
j'ai oublié de vous la mettre désolé Ah
c'est Google sans réflexion le buste
vers l'avant les la tête entre les mains
et on peut aller voir ouais wesh les
sauts et Aniche alors moi j'avais
j'avais pronostiqué que ce serait la
Turbo nul du jour en fait ça a été
Nakamura Carlsen
dans trois minutes on aura l'Armageddon
donc on pourra le suivre je pense ah oui
ça ça va être ça va jouer une 3 à 4 5 6
donc là on est gâté matériel il y a un
pion isolé mais l'activité donc on
parlait on en parle tous les jours en
fait de ce qu'il faut faire quand on est
enfin quand on a un pion isolé donc
quand on a un pion isolé on joue actif
on garde les pièces on va essayer de
faire des menaces de faire des choses et
si on peut échanger depuis on décolle
puis un moment donné 5 D4 un truc comme
ça essayez vraiment d'échanger des pions
et de mettre la pression
à l'inverse c'est noir qui ont enfin qui
joue contre un pion isolé les noirs
doivent essayer de changer les pièces au
maximum et bien sûr de bloquer ce pion
isolé donc généralement le bloqueur
c'est pas la dame le meilleur blogueur
c'est un cavalier
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est une est-ce que c'est
une c'est une chambre il vient d'où non
ce n'est pas une parce qu'il y a pas
trop de coups
le règlement ça devrait être 30 coups ou
répétitions
par exemple
il y a une nul théorique sur la pire
avec un circuit de dame par exemple tu
as pas peur de me dire de jouer quoi
il y a aussi dans dans la Sicilienne
avec Caval G4 et catac le fouet 3 four
revient en cavale revient en F6 en fait
c'est les meilleurs coups tu peux arguer
que c'est les meilleurs coups pour les
deux camps effectivement faire de nul
comme ça bon après c'est quand même là
c'était vraiment en cas de coup quoi là
je suis d'accord qui est quand même 12
coups que voilà mais bon alors on voit
que normalement a commencé
alors si tu veux on va aller voir la
magdon et je peux même mettre la scène
que j'avais mis hier ça vous va
la scène avec les caméras
et plus la qualité celle-là voilà
regardez-moi cette partie
vous mettre bien sûr la la la partie de
Magnus
l'Armageddon voilà vous avez
la partie la pendule enfin l'échiquier
c'est un gambit du roi de la part de
Nakamura alors le Gambie du roi c'est
quand même une variante qui est réputée
pour être
paruté mais
pas très loin
[Musique]
rapidement comme du roi c'est F4 pour
être pas très très bon sur toi au niveau
Naka qui qui joue vraiment pour pour
l'attaque et les pions noirs de plus et
ben sont avancés là il y a le cavalier
F6 donc là Magnus qui rend le pion mais
à l'échange pas en échange du pion et
ben il force un petit peu si tu veux des
blancs ça fait plaisir sur case noir et
c'est vrai que le roi blanc est déjà
assez ouvert quoi
c'est Oliver
donc des trois cavaler ses 6
c'est leur magasin
l'Armageddon c'est la Turbo de haut du
dimanche et salut Oliver dans le chat
qui me fait de très beaux compliments
alors
Oliver c'est
quelqu'un qui qui adore qui adore
trouver des sosies Alain et à l'autre
d'accord bah il est plutôt plutôt sympa
dans son comparaison et désolé c'est
tout parce que ça fait quand même deux
minutes que je commande dans le vide
j'avais coupé mon micro par inadvertance
d'accord
[Rires]
mais à chaque fois qu'il me voit l'hiver
il me dit que je ressemble beaucoup à
Stéphane Bressac
et et à chaque fois il me le fait il me
l'a fait
je sais pas combien de fois sur twitch
et il est même venu sur Youtube me le
faire en commentaire de mes vidéos et
donc voilà taquine ressemblance
on les a jamais vu les deux dans la même
pièce en tout cas non
aka qui fait sa première réflexion moi
je trouve que j'aime bien la pose des
blancs là et un petit coup de cavale
étroit Caval des 5 on va être beau moi
j'aime bien les noirs
sont un peu ouvertes et qu'il y a un
problème de
développement moi je ferais ces trois
pour te dire parce que j'ai cahier des
cartes J'en ai horreur mais bon qui
arrive en fait même qu'est-ce qu'avait
là je sais pas si je vais là ou là c'est
une que je pourrais venir là et tu vas
où maintenant si je viens là
je vais en E2
et du F3 qui peut bien sûr arriver
j'ai l'impression que la l'ouverture de
la cas c'est pas forcément bien placé
bien passé
donc avoir un peu ce qu'il fait un
peut-être G3 possible non je pense ça va
pas la ça va un peu dégueu
non tu commençais par ces trois toi pour
essayer de tenir au moins la case
maintenant qu'il y avait
il commence par
intelligent
un coup cher à Samira
5 pairs un coup donc bien sûr je G4 j'ai
pas j'ai pas pris hein parce que je suis
cloué mais j'ai cavalué 5 les
fourchettes
ça va être la fin des haricots au bout
du coup
c'est marrant qu'il se prennent
miniature parce que ils ont fait nuls
enfin à mieux arranger
on aurait pu dire quasiment handicaux tu
vois et là et là une un énorme agrément
du coup ça a l'air d'un coup en deux
parties c'est pas mal moi ça serait la
journée plutôt tranquille pour le l'ex
champion du monde effectivement ouais
il avait pas l'air surpris du tout
Magnus il a directement accepté le
gambiroit et la poussée G5 comme un boss
standards et puis bon il est en blitz la
pendule Magnus à moins de temps qui
carot hein ma venue à 7 minutes contre
10 et là on est déjà à 6 contre 5
alors il a d'abord fait de la F2 pour se
prémunir pour pas perdre un tempo sur
cavale Deca tout cavale 5 et ensuite il
a fait le développement finalement avec
cavale C3 et food est fou D2 et les deux
camps font grand rock maintenant
mais il y a du mal à bouger des petits S
avec les avec les voyez c'est un peu
bizarre les Noirs ont plus de on sent le
meilleur centre je pense à un moment il
y a un dessin qui va arriver
un jeu qui est quand même plus actif le
fou je joue pas le foot
[Musique]
le roi il y a un vis-à-vis j'aime pas du
tout la position
pour ça moi
avec un tel avantage qui propose
d'échanger les dames
a été joué
que il faut que je garde un peu les
pièces
ok ouais la barre la barre effectivement
elle a l'air de bien d'accord avec
Margus sur ce coup est-ce qu'on mettrait
pas le cavalent E2 depuis le fou on
s'est trois
pas mal mais attention à vis-à-vis qui
va toujours être un problème et puis il
peut y avoir deux en l'air aussi en plus
il y a dans certaines variante en tout
cas
moi je vous rappelle la cadence c'est 7
minutes pour les noirs pour les blancs
et arriver au 40e coup les joueurs se
verront retrouver gagné une seconde
parcours jusqu'à la fin de la partie
le champion du monde Blitz c'est rapide
oui oui bien sûr après Naka c'est pas un
peintre non plus hein
en fait je pense que là on a vraiment
les deux meilleurs joueurs en but c'est
rapide ouais il doit avoir quelques il
doit avoir quelques titres aussi
mondiaux le NACA en fait en rapide ou
quoi
ah ouais il a envie de verrez il a été
absent il a été absent souvent
c'est vrai et puis après là
je pense qu'il a rien mais tu peux
tester je crois qu'en Bliss il en a pas
mais il me semble qu'il en a en rapide
je vérifie
et
[Musique]
donc je sais pas si la vente
il sort connait pas le nom mais en tout
cas c'est clair que là il y a eu un raté
de ça apparemment il y avait un coup
gagnant
gagnant enfin un coup avec quoi avantage
c'est pas lequel c'était attends je vais
te dire mais
je sors la turbinette et le coin à deux
peut-être un leboncoin c'était D5 là
pour les noirs
change un peu d'avis après donc on va
peut-être pas trop lui faire confiance
sur un blitz Giroir
on dit que les Blancs tiennent plus ou
moins l'équilibre mais effectivement ils
ont moins bonne position déjà ça se voit
donc G3 on profite du
clouage ici pour attaquer l'option F4
manger et ça prend à 4 côté
là mais il y a plein de choses qui
peuvent s'échanger là être un faucon F4
qui va les points F4 impossible
et déjà on commence à la position
commence à sécher un peu
ouais il veut jouer pour l'avantage
attention à ce que
ce serait une double attaque une
fourchette
c'est contrôlé j'ai rien dit
ce serait bien qu'on puisse attaquer à
deux un jour quand même c'est ça
qui es-tu en toi je ne te connais pas
je me présente vite fait je me présente
vite fait Michel sniper
1800 fit ah ouais ouais enfin je suis
plein d'autres choses aussi à Slate mais
je suis je travaille pour chaise.com au
secteur international principalement sur
les traductions
et voilà qui me présente super bien en
fait merci beaucoup super
comme j'ai trois c'est le coup que
j'aurais fait et c'est un coup à bon
parce que c'est pas bon
au moins ce que l'ordinateur
de défendre à deux pour faire B3 ok donc
c'est cette même idée
il veut manger à deux avec le fou ouais
puis comme ça il y aura pas B3 parce
qu'il pourra sacrifier le fou en B3 je
pense arriver à une attaque peut-être
je sais pas
j'ai envie que Nakamura prenne un
cavalier 4 maintenant pour qu'on voit ce
qui se passe
il te laisse manger à deux il veut te le
donner
le temps qui est quasiment enfin
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a Samir Robin
qui se moque de mon palmarès dans le
chat j'apprécie pas trop
mais j'ai un palmarès figure-toi
champion de Nantes 2022 et c'est pas des
cracks
il attaque à 7 il s'en laisse pas
compter le gars
dans la partie
et là on est on est en train de voir
l'inverse on voit Naka qui va manger à 7
à Magnus
il va menacer maintenant c'est pas rien
ça ça
et peut-être un coup de fou c'est 6 pour
essayer d'avoir la case au loin en D7
peut-être même fouet 5 je dis ça mais il
a mangé des trois ou Cécile alors une
baisse tout ça sept à deux ils veulent
pas se manger un
quatre
il défend il y a un problème
ça peut être très compliqué même cavaler
ces quatre fourchettes scorpion prend je
mange du fou ou de la tour c'est un peu
de venir catastrophique très très vite
là pour pour Naka comment est-ce qu'il
va paraître
elle est très embêtante Dame des quatre
ça reste quand même fort ça aussi
ça va un peu vite pour moi aussi il a
pris à deux finalement
et je me toujours mieux la position des
Noirs assez largement même ok cavalier
qui saute quand même bien cavalier il va
faire des choses Nakamura mais
effectivement le parcours de la table
il fait plaisir ce parcours de la dame
comme ça aussi
il y a deux trois qui ont l'air tout
simplement
à faire et la plus qu'une minute à la
pendule
on comprend son malheur il y a un peu
plus pour les noirs et
un meilleur ROI Magnus a commencé avec 7
minutes contre 10 Ah maintenant 2
minutes contre 50 secondes
il a remis son roi en B1 c'est un coup
lent forcément mais est-ce qu'il avait
le choix pas vraiment j'aime bien qu'il
y avait des cartes qui va arriver
ça va être
très très embêtant et les pièces du
carreau allaient le roi qui qui rites
le fameux le fameux puzzle
30 secondes pour Naka
trouver une défense déjà très difficile
qui est sur dame là qu'est-ce qu'il veut
faire il a fait la grimace d'un il est
en train de faire des petites têtes là
tu sais en train de froncer les sourcils
il bouge la tour il va partir avec son
roi cavaler des quatre
secondes tous ces deux
échecs on ramasse la tour
abandon alors c'est juste calme c'est
juste une cale pour l'instant
je sais pas j'ai pas compris ok là il y
a peut-être tout pour eux ouais deux
ça va être terminé ou c'est joli hein tu
crois prends
ah oui j'ai pris
pas mais j'ai les bras levés chez moi
abandon de la part de
la part de Naka alors on a rien compris
à cette partie 4 secondes
j'ai pas compris là
Magnus impressionnant mais il a raté des
trucs j'ai l'impression qu'il y avait
pas mal de de fail notamment ici le
fameux fou dessin alors
gagner en ligne il a choisi de il a
choisi de jouer tout tempo
ça élimine le fou qui allait manger là
et bon c'est vrai que en terme de calcul
en partie lente c'est vu mais c'est vrai
qu'en Blitz tout ça et là j'ai pris des
5 je pense pour assurer quoi moi
t'inquiète pas j'ai pas vu la suite
[Musique]
on terminé on va revenir sur une sur une
autre scène
une scène où on va plus se voir
qui sont ici
et 3 4 5 6 7 8 bon et donc on peut jouer
à 4 on se demande
et apparemment il n'a pas envie de jouer
au 4
une idée que si je fais 4 trop vite et
bien toutes ces changer comme on avait
dit ouais je pense que c'est ça il a pas
envie d'ouvrir le centre tant que ces
pièces sont pas idéalement placées
[Musique]
que Abdou joue E4 mais Abdou ne pas
ajouter tout de suite donc voilà en tout
cas
il y a eu ici
four à 3
est-ce qu'on va voir ainsi un soir
où est-ce qu'on va voir juste
l'échange de coup
les conseils pour le milieu de jeu j'ai
300 et l'autre
paire de fou meilleur dans les positions
alors déjà
le conseil que je te donnerai pour
t'améliorer déjà cette faire des
tactiques
d'améliorer ton calcul c'est important
et surtout de faire attention aux pièces
emprise ça c'est hyper important ensuite
quand tu commences la partie et ben tu
sais qu'il y a déjà
bon des règles d'or qu'on utilise en
début de partie comme par exemple
prendre le centre avec tes pions sortir
les pièces mineures c'est les cavalier
les fous comme les cavaliers ici et les
fous bien sûr par le rock très très vite
dès que tu peux le faire parce que le
roi c'est la personne la plus importante
de la partie et que tu pourras comment
s'attaquer uniquement quand le roi sera
en sécurité une fois que les pièces
mineures sont sorties et que le roi
étant sécurité tu peux passer aux pièces
lourdes qui sont les tours pardon je
vais mettre une couleur les tours et la
dame les sortir toujours vers le centre
ici d'être cohérent avec ce que tu fais
tu vas vers le centre mais toutes les
pièces vers le centre ou vers les
colonnes qui vont s'ouvrir donc
il y a pas de pions éventuellement
et regarde les vidéos de stouf bien
évidemment vous avez vous avez que je
fais des vidéos sur YouTube donc mon ma
chaîne vidéo Youtube c'est tout donc
c'est c'est assez facile à retenir à ses
décrire sous mon nom là juste là voilà
et
aussi je fais des streams quasiment tous
les jours sauf là pendant le événement
c'est un peu compliqué j'ai beaucoup de
travail mais mon mon twitch c'est stouf
pour ceux qui me connaissent pas je vous
invite à suivre ma chaîne et acheter un
peu tout ce que nous faisons en stream
et bien sûr on essaie aussi de vous
faire progresser à travers aussi les
stream aussi
pour l'hiver là je suis passé de John
Travolta à Philippe Caubert je sais pas
si j'apprécie vraiment
on n'est pas dans la progression là
il suggère à un bruit de tout 2000 pour
moi avec toi en coach voilà
j'ai passé l'âge pour ce genre de
dinguerie
c'était le mois dernier après donc
courageant mais
je peux aller à ouais je pense je peux
aller à 1009 mais plus ça va être
compliqué OK
après c'est dans la tête c'est beaucoup
dans la tête
c'est dans l'âge aussi là je ne rajeunit
pas
les spectateurs du chat me comprendront
il y a toujours ce fou en à 3 qui est là
qui bouge pas
et maintenant que la dame est partie un
petit peu à se promener par ici d'être
voir si maintenant on peut réagir au
centre avec le cap
donc d'ailleurs c'est une réaction qui
m'a un petit peu surpris
pour essayer de prendre la colonne c'est
qui dit 4 10 pions isolés je croyais que
tu détestais les yeux
peut-être que là il y avait prise qui
avait les B5 qui pose problème il y a
des trucs un peu partout
et peut-être que c'est un souci pour
pour le noir ici c'est pour ça qu'il a
préféré manger de l'autre option
[Musique]
candidat pour pour les blancs et il y a
aussi cette idée de faire cavaler les
deux toujours F3 et E4 aussi qui reste
bien sûr
dans les dans les idées mais bon
[Musique]
cavale F4 parce que ce serait une belle
case pour ce cavale la case F4
je le vois un peu dominer ici ouais en
fait tu peux te faire classer dans la
parole de 5 jours même si
je pense que
chacun de nous en fait on va voir une
réaction au centre je pense que la
réaction on va arriver plus vite
et de faire un truc comme ça quoi
je sais pas si c'est bien mais essayez
d'ouvrir rapidement la position certes
j'ai un pion étonné mais tu as aussi un
fou qui joue pas donc c'est pas si clair
mais je me dis que si je fais des trucs
comme ça qui perdent quand même pas mal
de temps ben j'ai peur qu'à un moment
donné je me prenne pas un coup avec C5
rapidement et j'arrive avec les Noirs à
pousser la majorité et si je touchais à
rien quand tu me fais ça 5 en fait
j'aimerais bien faire un jour cinq
secondes mais ça c'était dans mes rêves
j'ai plus fou ouais mais c'est lent
aussi tu me dis que mes plans sont lents
mais ça c'est 5 c'est 4 même quand c'est
arrivé ça fait toujours pas grand chose
de tout ça c'est que tu arriveras pas
[Musique]
à la base
une des idées les plus principales j'ai
aussi peau à 6 qui a un coup peut-être
échangé mon mauvais coup qu'on tombe
beaucoup
échanger quand je voudrais regarde un
jour si ça en l'air donc il faut être
précis il faut calculer j'ai aussi les
aider des cavaliers E4 maintenant c'est
moi qui lui contre la casa
écoute avant je pouvais jamais faire ça
parce que peut-être trop nombreux à
dessus donc je sais pas j'aime pas trop
cavalier aux deux parce que j'ai
l'impression que tu abandonnes vraiment
les deux principales qui un jour de
jouer le cas ouais en fait s'il est pour
toi s'il est blanc font pas la rupture
assez rapidement ils abandonnent
l'initiative au nom et presque ben je me
dis que si tu le fais pas vite c'est moi
qui vais le faire ok mais après voilà je
sais pas
avoir
alors carwana c'est intéressant
il a balancé le pion h et c'est aussi
pour ça
j'imagine que tu arrives possède la
question de savoir ce qu'il a l'air OK
ou pas alors on s'est arrêté je sais
plus trop où on s'était arrêté bah
justement au moment où il réfléchissait
très longtemps pour roquerary il a pas
fait qu'elle va le baiser cette il a
fait petit rock au 10e coup et ensuite
donc karwana a appris à tempo en F6
et envoyé à chaque fois
alors cavalas si il a réfléchi
H5 et c'est 5 alors là il se passe les
choses très intéressantes
d'idée des choses qui sont un petit peu
avec tous les nouveaux modules
maintenant les stocks fiches les
tout ce que vous pouvez connaître comme
gros module de d'ouverture d'analyses le
pion H qui sont tout le temps balancés
les pions ah d'ailleurs aussi jusqu'en
jusqu'à la 6e rangée
ça c'est pas classique autre chose
maintenant vous voyez que l'idéal 5
c'est clairement de un jour mangeant G6
d'ouvrir la colonne h et de mater le
Renoir en G8 en tout cas attaquer
disait
sacrifice sacrifice maths
sacrifice sacrifice maths et c'est donc
d'ailleurs pour ça cette raison là
que les Blancs n'ont pas encore ok parce
qu'ils gardent l'option pouvoir attaquer
là-haut le problème c'est que dans ces
positions
tu sais quand tu attaques un fiancéto
c'est-à-dire ici j'attaque un affaire
keto c'est quand on a fait comme ça avec
un petit fou au milieu vous voyez ça
c'est
serait bien d'avoir le footcas noir en
fait pour l'attaquer exactement ça
normalement normalement
quand j'attaque sur un champ ghetto
adverse si moi j'ai pas le fou de la
couleur normalement il y a jamais marre
par exemple regarder un jeu des coups
débile juste pour comprendre ok
je fais exprès j'attends
et en fait tu pourras pas mater en suite
et ça ne bouge plus d'un poil tu m'as
jamais et par contre si tu avais le fou
pèse moi j'aurais pu échanger des fous
ou mettre un fou ici etc j'aurais pu
faire un peu mieux bon là j'ai fait
découvrir
mais on va on va pas faire ça bien sûr
mais ça c'est juste pour illustrer à
quel point en fait l'attaque elle ne
mène normalement nulle part si je veux
balancer là-bas
mais alors qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
se pourquoi c'est quoi son plan en fait
à carwana si si c'est pas de matelas le
roi noir c'est quoi ton planche après il
peut quand même affaiblir le roi grâce à
ça et plus tard ramener des pièces
c'était le matin par exemple peut-être
que je passe je vais peut-être tourner
un taquet menacer ici un jour ramener
les cavaliers peut-être qu'un jour j'ai
du jeu tu vois mais en tout cas le match
sera pas immédiat là j'ai quand même
bien le temps de venir défendre etc
donc c'est pour ça que moi quand je vois
ça attaque là je me dis
pas vraiment l'idée à cause de
ouais on salut les cloches de l'église
espagnole
et je m'inquiète pas trop pour les Noirs
par rapport au roi parce que je sais que
dès qu'il y a un échange et ben écoute
enfin dès que ça va attaquer je
fous donc priori ça va aller et là ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'il y a un petit
dicton qui dit attention glissement à
elle je connais la suite la vie est
belle
la réaction au centre réaction au centre
voilà donc il a fait ça donc là il a
fait aussi un miroir
et sur H5 et ben c'est 5 réactions
et maintenant la question moi je vais
essayer d'ouvrir le centre la question
c'est où est-ce que tu mettes ton roi
parce qu'à un moment donné moi je vais
essayer de tout casser et t'ouvrir le
centre
sachant que je vais me faire H5 avec ma
tour était là et à la base je voulais
ramener ma tour pour l'attaque quand
rock ok mais moi j'ai une colonne
ouverte ici je vais attaquer ouvrir et
voilà et mettre le roi au centre bon tu
vois ça c'est grand côté cimetière ça me
plaît pas du tout ouais mais bon
quand même pas mais après même H6 plus
tard ce n'est qu'un bouton
moi j'ai voté
je crois que si je parie je pourrais pas
finir et je parie pas je vous laisse il
y a Oliver qui me demande si je suis
polyglotte je ouais je parle couramment
anglais ça fait déjà deux langues on
peut dire que c'est poli glotte
après il faudrait qu'il y a un modo qui
viennent ah oui d'accord donner la fin
penché les gars vous avez si vous voulez
vous avez une prédiction je vous laisse
avec voter
il voulait mon avis moi j'avais parié
secrètement pour
alors moi je sais plus pour qui j'ai
parié donc
tu vois pas
j'avais dit nul je peux pas voter
fallait mettre nul dans ton sondage mais
ok bon
après c'est chaud il peut passer
n'importe quoi
ouais bon français français toujours
bref mais mon doigt hyper on va dire
sur le truc ok ouais ouais sur le
sondage
les sommes que tu me dois aussi avec
tous ces paris perdus pour l'instant on
est à 20 euros
[Rires]
dans le grand n'importe quoi
c'est vrai
c'est vrai alors voter si vous gagnez
plein de points tous les points de
l'humains on a perdu une tonnière donc
faut encore voter pour pour encore aller
lui prendre tout ce qui lui reste
il a bien réfléchi car Wana et il a fait
tourner donc déjà grand rock c'est une
idée qu'on oublie et surtout il laisse
il laisse faire Caval B4 maintenant
est-ce que ça
est-ce que c'est juste à côté dans l'eau
ou est-ce que c'est vraiment embêtant
parce que ça force la dame à se mettre
sur une case vraiment passive je pense
ouais
et d'ailleurs d'ailleurs tour bien c'est
un combat ça renforce le plan des quatre
on veut pas ouvrir la pollution on veut
pas avoir depuis isolé etc avec les
Blancs bien sûr donc vraiment veut
manger le pain des quatre avec une pièce
quoi qui met toutes les pièces dessus
donc là déjà avec tourner on a la
formation qui veut pas revenir
sinon il l'aurait fait mais c'est une
partie qui
arrive
peut-être mettre le roi tranquillement
en F1 en fait
le roi en F 1 la tour qui va s'activer
via H3
en fait je peux jouer je peux j'ai pas
mal de choses mais ce qui est clair
c'est que
je pense avoir une partie chaude moi je
vois bien un petit
alors dans ce cas là on va mettre le
pion en H6 à vendre ok peut-être
[Musique]
c'est que après dame D2 prie a prise des
4 et maintenant j'ai pas d'âme prend des
cartes à cause de la fourchette et oui
donc du coup si ça se passe comme ça
il me fait ça c'est bien vu je pense que
je jouerai peut-être ça
moi j'ai pris la part de fou et quand on
fou qui est si important
je mélange
mais bon c'est bien emprise moi ça reste
compliqué
ça peut être une idée pour les Noirs
quand même complètement complètement
après sur ça que je peux pas aller aussi
en deux
pour avoir la même idée et garder comme
ça
mais tu vas pas
prendre du
pain je propose des
tours et à la fin il y a pas Caval c'est
de
et en plus on attaque le cavalier
cavale revient en C6 peut-être gagner un
tempo sur la tour à la fin qui serait en
décale ah non non excuse moi j'étais
j'étais plus beaucoup plus loin j'étais
après tous les jours des quatre
je vais faire ça
en l'air oh là là
en plus dès qu'il vient de ton four tu
me donnes la raison de rattaquer
vraiment sur ah ouais là c'est vraiment
la cata
ok mais en tout cas il faut qu'il trouve
un truc actif maintenant alors C4 c'est
aussi une idée c'est 4 pour fermer mais
ça s'inscrit pas dans la réaction au
centre dont tu parlais tout à l'heure
quoi mais ces quatre ça reste l'idée
tout le temps en général
je sais pas
en tout cas sincère riche mais
Paris qui réveille quand même pas mal
autant
ouais il est déjà on est on est au 15
même pas au 15e coup il a déjà dépensé
près de la moitié de son temps
c'est très risqué on l'a bien vu ce que
ça lui a fait hier contre elle nous a
tort enfin ça le fait par une partie
quand même
juste pour répondre aux messages de
Oliver et de Kiki c'est un salarié de
cheeseccum a le droit de son litchi
en fait je vois pas le problème bah oui
de toute façon
[Musique]
moi je peux pas moi je passe à l'arrière
mais moi qui a un contrat stream tu sais
je peux pas stream sur les chaises ça me
paraît normal ah oui ça c'est normal oui
mais après ben je raconte les pièces
j'ai raconté comme j'avais même compte
chez 24
j'ai tous les comptes enfin juste un
genre d'échec et je suis partout quoi
en ce moment-là bah oui mais bon
d'ailleurs tout ça c'est juste tu vois
même tout le monde regarde un inca il
sur les pièces sur cascade aussi enfin
je regarde tout le monde de partout à un
moment donné tu as le droit de jouer
quoi enfin il a joué Caval B4
les deux sites sont dans une dans un
état d'esprit tellement différent que
c'est pas
c'est pas vraiment concurrentiel les
deux je pense
tellement différent le modèle donc
quel est intéressante cette partie il y
a entre Abdou et
fille roux le centre
le centre c'est toujours pas ouvert il y
a toujours pas eu cette histoire de 4
que tu préconisais il a joué un coup
très bizarre on peut aller regarder là
le coup de nos diabète
allez il a joué tout B1 vraiment
mystique
sur A5 combien
à moi 1800 hello ça passe crème ça je me
sache je m'en prends un à tous les
dimanches j'adore
donc on a quand même provoqué à 5 grâce
à ton bien donc chaque coup de pion ça a
publié quand même un peu la position
donc jamais contre de de penser
l'adversaire
est-ce que Abdou serait pas en train
d'essayer de commencer à préparer quatre
enfin
c'est bizarre quand même tourbé il y a
une raison profonde en fait je pense
qu'il a voulu forcer mais en fait il
était pas obligé de faire à 5 à l'irza
il aurait pu simplement rapatrié la dame
on le sait
tu peux donc c'est bizarre ce coup de
tourbé quand même non c'est quoi la
raison profonde après une raison
profonde s'appelle de toute façon de
jouer la minorité
de jouer avec B4 B5
[Musique]
il a fait une faiblesse en B6
etc
donc cavalier là tu pourras plus faire
ça
ça offre quand même pas mal de
possibilités donc après je sais pas ça a
été
joué
essayer de faire à trois B4
mais si je préparais à trois peut-être
que dans bedo est pas débile
par exemple
ça prend beaucoup de temps pour cette
idée là donc peut-être que c'est pas du
tout être le coup là il empêche le 4
et il y a peut-être même qu'elle va être
un coup jouer par fil possible
mais est-ce que c'est possible ça c'est
pas clair
finalement il va l'empêcher de pousser
les raisins
ouais si on peut on peut le faire
maintenant
on peut le faire maintenant
je vais revenir
[Musique]
et qui peut être faible donc le 4 je
pense ça va être ça va être le sous
conditions
parce que là je pense que on va opter
pour le plan A3 B4 je pense j'ai
l'impression qu'on n'a pas assez de
compensation dynamique pour cet
affaiblissement du pion central en fait
une fois qu'on a échangé tout en 4
je vois pas de follow up comme disent
les Anglais pas de suite immédiate
qui serait forte
comme tu as dit et je me retrouve à
devoir reculer
il y va pour A3 B4
clairement ce qu'il va se jouer je suis
content parce qu'on est quand même assis
dans l'esprit on comprend un peu ce qui
se passe dans la complexité de ces
positions
donc c'est
intéressant est-ce qu'on a souvent un
petit tour ça fait un moment qu'on n'a
pas vu donc il y a plein de parties à
ces plats quand même aujourd'hui
sur dame 5 tu peux le montrer il y avait
x 3
ok ça me va
OK
là il a fait d'affilée il a fait comment
elle était où elle était en fait
ah ouais il a fait un triangle un
quadrilatère de l'espace avec sa dame
bon après il a réussi à provoquer un
affaiblissement chez lazy parce que il y
a pion C4 qui est isolé
ment ce qui va se passer il y a ici en
C4 mais il y a une faiblesse sur le long
terme sur très très fort en F3 et le
coup D7 c'est lui qui ne peut pas
vraiment venir dans ce 6 parce qu'il y
aura cavalier point genre un problème
avec la paire de fou des blanches et de
pions faibles en C6 mais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de ce foodcasse blanche on cherche
tout là c'est vraiment une galère je me
demande si un jour il pourra pas jouer
le 5 ou alors jouer avec pour B8 B6
ça donne des cases
d'abord un cavalier de 17 pour venir en
C5 pour bloquer ce pion faire maintenant
pour un F6 pour concurrencer un petit
peu chauffe-eau en B2 et après essayer
de faire en sorte
ment de pièces c'est vrai franchement
cavalier je sais pas si je mets vraiment
le coup ici ou c'est aussi son F5
mais essayez de sortir un peu les pièces
et c'est vrai que là si jamais j'arrive
pas à sortir des pièces ça va être
compliqué là je peux pas
ça en fait ça le problème
Michel qui nous envoie que c'est sans
doute c'est une partie qui ressemble
beaucoup à une zoukerte jouée par
youssouphof alors ça c'est de la belle
ref qui est très peur
[Musique]
très possible Michel je ne connais pas
toutes les parties du bord pourtant je
suis un grand fan j'ai tous ces livres
sur son Kiss Cool là j'ai tous les
bouquins chez moi
donc
[Musique]
j'ai dû en lire un demi sur peut-être la
six bouquins que j'ai
c'est incroyable ce qu'il a fait on peut
retourner voir s'il te plaît nous dire
bec parce que je trouve que c'est
incroyable ce qu'il a fait d'ailleurs
j'ai perdu un de mes bouquins que
j'avais acheté je l'ai oublié dans
l'avion
c'était c'était le tome
qui était qui s'appelait
genre
tournemment préparation je crois c'est
comme ça on parle de Arthur Youssoupha
c'est ça
Welling ils doivent avoir un petit un
petit support qui traîne quelque part
rien à personne en plus quoi
et alors ouais c'est incroyable ce qu'il
a fait de nous dire Beck tu vois parce
qu'il a il a fait son petit tour B1 pour
forcer à 5 ou je ne sais quoi et
maintenant que les raisins a mis son
cavale en E4 qui l'occupe cette case hop
ça remet la tour en C1 après il y avait
aussi un une raison tactique c'est que
si je faisais à apprendre qui n'avance
pas ça et de nouveau ça
ça défonce cavalier ça prépare une bonne
fois pour toute
est-ce qu'on peut encore empêcher
tactiquement d'une manière ou d'une
autre la poussée à trois non
je vois pas comment je peux t'empêcher
de le faire
ah non je pense que cette fois il va
pouvoir le faire enfin son A3 mais après
ce qui va se passer c'est que filou il
va essayer j'imagine de de d'anticiper
tout ça enfin tout à l'heure on avait
parlé des différentes manières de
pouvoir anticiper
[Musique]
un attaque minorité imaginons si je fais
un truc comme ça je sais juste de jouer
des coups
B5 par exemple là un médecin qui est
intéressant moi j'ai envie de jouer F5
là c'est tout je veux dire dans la pose
dans la pose actuelle
[Musique]
ouais mais je t'expliquer pourquoi
j'aime pas
attends
annuler le jeu des blancs
en C4 et ben je pourrais manger dans des
pions et avoir un pion passé
pardon je pense que je suis là je me
cabane en dessin qui pourrait être
faible donc c'est un tu vois genre de de
de
réponse de réaction qu'on peut voir chez
les Noirs même si c'est vrai que ça
paraît bizarre le fou qui joue pas qui
va permettre
que F5 j'aime pas parce que ça
bloquerait mon fou tout le temps et F5
en fait c'est un coup qui a l'air fort
dans l'idée ça ça défend bien le le non
mais c'est tout je veux faire F5 pour F4
ouais ok alors en fait moi ce que je
veux faire parce qu'en fait moi quand je
vois F5 je vois un truc je me dis que la
cadassin qu'elle est plus contrôlée par
un pion
un truc comme ça et éventuellement
échanger un cavalier contre un cavalier
mon fou quand on cavalier par exemple et
ma Claude cavalier en E5 voici
et donc là tu veux faire F5 F4 ok c'est
parti je vais ramener mon cavalier en V3
et je commence par revenir ici tu
pourras pas faire déjà tu vois après je
sais pas peut-être que tu peux faire gs5
mais je me dis que c'est un peu tout
match
il faut vraiment que toi parce que tu as
publié un pas mal ces cases là et sur le
long terme ça peut être le détour et
deuxièmement si tu avais décidé un jour
de retirer ton coup quelque part ou si
tu veux par exemple faire un truc de ce
style là la réponse enfin la réaction
qu'on a vu avec B5 t'en fous tu devras
donc en fait
bon là on part de stratégie et de
placement de pièces vous voyez c'est
c'est un peu moins concret que si on
calculé
là on sait plus d'anticiper les
déplacements de pièces et
d'un point de vue positionnel F5 j'aime
pas du tout parce que ça
ça me fait mes pièces ça donne à 1500
mais après peut-être que peut-être que
bah écoute concrètement peut-être que ça
ça peut-être que ça ça va
je crois pas mais peut-être que ça
j'avoue j'aurais pas osé mais F5 ce
serait un coup qui m'aurait qui m'aurait
traverser l'esprit assez rapidement
je dis pas que je l'aurais joué mais oui
effectivement mais l'idée j'aurais
réfléchi aux deux coups mais là dans la
partie lui il a fait cavale G5
d'ailleurs
il a fait quel est le 5 ouais
intéressant ça
il échange des pièces qui défendent
comme ça
c'est pas trop ça a pas l'air très dur à
défendre pour l'instant pour les blancs
mais ok non non mais bon
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les Blancs là
on est obligé de prendre quasiment parce
que Caval D2 c'est passif ça recule bon
bien sûr on n'a pas trouvé le roi ça
c'est une évidence non soit je mange
soit
avec F3
même et F3 en même temps c'est les cases
noires autour qui sont très faibles et
j'aime pas trop trop faire F3 et après
en même temps je pensais pas que Serge
pourrait
avoir donc
je peux aussi faire un fou 2 peut-être
mais pour deux je sais pas trop il faut
voir vraiment la suite
parce que je garde mon idée mais bon les
Noirs je pense qu'ici ils ont une
position qui est qui dort
en plus
mais avoir en tout cas c'est un coup
intéressant de la part de Fillon tu vois
ces pièces qui se marchent un peu dessus
on n'arrive pas à mettre deux cavaliers
en 4 il va en effet
je pense que c'est une grosse bataille
grosse bataille positionnée en fait pour
l'instant
les tactiques vont arriver dans dans 15
coups à peu près quand quelque chose va
s'ouvrir quand une colonne va s'ouvrir
quand quand une rupture de pion va avoir
lieu ça aura forcément lieu à un moment
mais là pour l'instant on cherche à
placer ces pièces au mieux et à les
raisins qui a choisi Caval G5
et ça fait réfléchir ne dire bec les
deux là au 20e coup ils sont ils
arrivent vers la moitié du temps ça va
être une partie très disputée celle-là
ça va être chaud les deux joueurs qui
veulent gagner en plus
et ça c'est ça c'est bien parce que
généralement les Noirs cherchent à avoir
l'égalité sauf que firou il veut pas
pour la gamme pour pour gagner
côté orientari c'est rentrer dans la
variante dont on parlait tout à l'heure
il a fait il a fait dame de
gros changement
on s'est arrêté à quel moment je me suis
un peu trop ah il y avait une
proposition de nulle
il a mis la dame en Détroit Wesley
pour vous monsieur
rock
G5 ou G3
cavalage 5 on va s'étendre
[Musique]
h c'est normal donc avec il est pas venu
en E2 pour défendre le fou donc pour
venir bloquer ce pion isolé vous savez
que votre imprimé on va bloquer
le pion et on va essayer d'échanger les
pièces avec les blancs et les Noirs dans
le dynamique
de dynamisme chez les
[Musique]
a tout joué tempo jusqu'à cavale E2 de
caroanna le coûte 17 cavale 2 c'est là
qu'il a commencé à réfléchir à niche ça
l'a amené à la prendre en G3
et depuis la position qui a l'air alors
selon les modules elle est parfaitement
égale effectivement l'analyse humaine on
n'est pas on n'est pas loin de penser
pareil quand même
parce que
l'avantage de la perte de fou certes
mais pur isolé
et surtout le fait le foot casse blanche
peut-être fou G4 mais il y aurait juste
F3 donc tu aurais juste à rentrer chez
toi il a pas d'avenir se fout de casse
blanche j'ai l'impression
non
une mauvaise pièce ouais c'est une
mauvaise pièce c'est assez impression
pour l'instant
c'est un pion mais c'est solide c'est
solide là peut-être
garder un peu les pièces s'activer
mais bon non je je vois une belle
belle nulle ici de la part de nos deux
joueurs on l'avait annoncé celle là
donc là par rapport
par rapport à ce qu'on avait
proposé comme résultat moi j'avais dit
Hikaru gagne et quinzaine les
l'Armageddon pour l'instant j'ai tout
bon et j'avais dit dans celle-là bon nul
toi aussi tu as mis nul en terme de
gains ici est-ce que c'est chaud est-ce
que c'est guéri dira
et après tu avais dit ma mère Google je
t'avais moi j'avais mis
je pense qu'il va un petit peu souffrir
moi j'ai mis trop cache
pour Kawana c'est tout est possible
encore possible
[Musique]
qui sont assez compliquées alors j'ai eu
si tu veux j'ai eu des
comment dire
interview vous voulez voir on va se
regarder ça malheureusement j'ai pas une
interview de la partie de Naka et
par contre j'ai mis une interview de
Naka avant la partie et une de famille
avant la partie on va si tu veux on peut
aller se voir ça rapidement façon
parce que là il y a un petit creux à un
moment où est plus grand chose
c'est pile le moment pour aller regarder
ça
en anglais et après je vous fais une
petite petite traduction pour ceux qui
ont du mal avec la langue de Shakespeare
sport Hummer ayum parle pas bien anglais
je vous envoie
au professionnel
alors que s'est-il passé
les journalistes norvégiens c'était vrai
petit Fouine quand même là le mec lui a
demandé à Fabiano alors hier là
aujourd'hui tu joues contre l'adversaire
qui a complètement gâché sa chance hier
qui avait une partie gagnant et qu'il a
raté quoi dans quel état d'esprit tu vas
être il a dit mais c'est plutôt à lui
qu'il faut poser la question quand même
ce qui est assez légitime comme réponse
et après il lui a dit le Norvégien
journaliste est-ce que ça te donne envie
de jouer une ligne un peu risqué un peu
un peu enlevé et Fabienne elle a répondu
tu verras ça tu as pas répondu justement
on a eu un vrai petit filou un vrai
petit filou les joueurs les joueurs ne
dévoilent jamais leur premier coup avant
que le jouer ça c'est connu c'est normal
tu imagines un peu évidemment je
pourrais très bien interviewer et après
tu as un petit texto à un genre tiens
il va jouer
je sais pas il va te jouer à ton bons
ski quoi ou n'importe quelle ouverture
il veut il cherche un petit peu être
comme ça t'imagines si enfin bon voilà
quoi il cherche le scoop il cherche le
scoop
on se regarde Dakar maintenant
finance parkenne
[Musique]
le Hikaru il a fait des pas de géants au
niveau charisme il a vraiment trop la
classe il est rentré dans la salle et la
regarder l'échiquier géants qui étaient
devant l'entrée il y avait des gamins
qui jouaient il a dit ouais il a regardé
la pause il a dit ouais pas mal la pose
le gamin est gagnant il a une dame de
plus peut-être le futur Magnus on lui a
demandé on lui a demandé ensuite bah
alors qu'est-ce que tu en penses cette
partie contre Magnus tout le monde
l'attend avec impatience il a fait au
moins tu sais Magnus je le joue je le
joue quasiment toutes les semaines en
blitz sur Internet surchauss.com
d'ailleurs souvent c'est la vérité il
avait pas l'air impressionné c'est
normal et après on lui a demandé alors
elle va être comment la partie il a dit
bon ça peut être un truc de fou ou ça
peut être très ennuyeux vous le saurez
vite je viendrai vous voir dans le
confessionnal
maintenant on sait ce qui s'est passé ça
a été plutôt ennuyeux et il est mais il
a même pas eu le temps de passer au
confessionnal voilà mais en tout cas et
Caro la classe
ok
bon du coup il est un peu répondu que
Caravana est c'est vrai que par rapport
aux jours d'ouverture bah il a c'était
une le fameux Gambie
c'est quand même Magnus qui rentrait
dedans
pour pour faire nul et mais qu'il a reçu
autorisé donc c'est pour ça qu'il a dit
que ça dépendait de ce que peser Magnus
ma venue sur une partie plus longue avec
le plus D6 donc des 5
donc là c'est pour ça qu'il a qu'il
avait dit que ça va dépendre de ce que
fait Magnus au Magnus allez noir quand
comme ça ou annule ça
j'ignoré en fait que c'était une ligne
aussi annulante parce que à mon niveau
quand quelqu'un joue un Gambie mars en
amateur quelqu'un joue un gambler
Marshall il pour gagner généralement ça
donne des positions qui peuvent être
assez tendues ouais mais là c'est
tellement
tellement connu tout ça que bon à un
moment donné par rapport eux
c'est
assez clair quoi alors là une partie de
abdouk contre un filou alors il y a eu
cavalier français
il avait pas vu que son Caval G5 était
en prise donc là il se dit ah merde
heureusement il peut le reprendre de la
dame ou du pion coup de bol
franchement
bizarre après bon bah pour être pour une
idée
faire G4 mais ça serait vraiment du du
jamais vu quoi non mais bâtard
et il va taper sur
H36
ici et la réaction des blancs ça
pourrait être par exemple justement de
d'envoyer cette poussée 4
tout de suite encore une fois
salut Simon
salut Simon et éventuellement la dame
qui pourra venir en défense sur la
deuxième aussi déjà bien placé pour ça
il faudra revenir via dame 2 dame F3
cette dame mais ça abandonné le ça
abandonnerait le projet de A3 B4 à
l'aile dame
en tout cas il a réfléchi bien longtemps
de dire bec il a réfléchi 16 minutes ce
qui est vraiment un temps conséquent
en 16 minutes ce mec-là calcule sans
doute plus que vous dans toute votre
carrière donc
j'exagère à peine donc il a dû regarder
des lignes intéressantes et il s'est dit
que il y avait pas mieux que de prendre
en G5
avec les jouets
[Musique]
son cours on a parlé de 4
on va parler de A3 D4 moi je pense qu'il
y a plus sur un 3 qui va rester dans son
idée
parce que 4 mois de faire la prise en le
4 et d'avoir ce pion en D4 isolé en fait
donc moi je vois plus
un à trois ici
continuerez sur son plan sans doute
et c'est intéressant ce qui se passe du
côté de de maradjou
[Musique]
on est ici
on était on avait arrêté la position
après tours
vis-à-vis un tour d'âme à ce 5 où âge
classique
qui permet de prendre les cases
un peu ça a été un peu le flou
et tout c'est vite ok mais il a quand
même laissé la case B5 pour le foot
casse blanche et après ça doublerait les
pions c'est le cavalier prenait certes
mais est-ce que c'est si grave
mais moi j'aime pas du tout mais
pas pas tout de suite à chaque fois que
je dis un coup tu
penses des idées à lointaines oui
peut-être éventuellement mais là
actuellement je pense que le problème
à long terme ouais tu penses que ça
serait vraiment une très mauvaise idée
de se séparer de la paire de fou ça te
pose là parce qu'elle va s'ouvrir
de fou justement donc c'est chaud
on parle de 15 secondes
à voir si jamais elle arrive à jouer
cinq ou pas mais cela c'est vraiment des
gens qui enlève la pression sur la tour
c'est quand même pas mal peut-être B6 ça
arrive mais oui ps6
[Musique]
pas sur c'est plus une épine en fait
plus une despines que une faiblesse pour
l'instant le français
il est il est là il est là
non j'aime en fait il faut être là
arrive à changer de pièce si la noirie
mais là c'est vraiment au noir d'être
précis et de faire un truc
d'âne
alors on penser à le recycler ce fou via
C8 en fait alors ça dépend en fait de du
plan
il fait un projet 5 ça me paraît clair
je vais faire
attention ça laisserait si très faible
il y aurait déjà du Caval à 4 enfin
faudrait des sondages 3 d'abord certes
mais il y aurait du Caval A4 à taxer si
ça attaque B6 c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais après sur le long terme on pensait
que les blancs en laissent pas aussi à
prendre des cadres
il y a eu des rapports
ça fait super longtemps qu'il réfléchit
à
parce qu'il a bien dû se douter qu'il
allait prendre ce cavale
comme ça et je me dis ok j'ai ce coup-là
qui est très bien au pire des cas mais
j'ai un autre coup qui a l'air
intéressant et si jamais le jour je
réfléchirai
tout à l'heure
mais après oui c'est ça que ça reste une
idée donc bonjour
ça ça affaiblit quand même pas mal de
cartes blanches autour
de ces pions là moi je pensais faire
Kamel et F6 ca valait 4 et peut-être
maintenant faire ses 5 aussi
mais j'ai l'impression qu'à un moment il
va falloir la pousser cette structure à
elle dame côté noir parce qu'elle est
elle va être faible là pour l'instant
elle est tenue par le fou B7 et le Caval
d'essai mais quand eux ils iront
ailleurs pour peut-être attaquer bah ils
vont devenir très faible c'est
c'est peut-être donc c'est ça que
effectivement ça peut être une idée pour
jouer avec les pions pendant après si
moi je touche à rien on est blanc passe
les blancs rouges ah oui tu peux aussi
toucher à rien et oui il y aura toujours
l'idée à trois B4 je vais essayer de
toucher à rien avoir un petit peu et dès
que je suis BK j'arrive avec mon petit
dessin
effectivement comme Michel nous dit on
peut renforcer avec tour des 6 mais ça
m'a l'air hyper passif quoi cette tour
une idée de la ramener dans des six pour
la ramener en G6 là c'est occupé par le
fou mais je le connais Michel c'était
sûr que ton idée de faire ça
il est solide très solide
Michelin
ça marche qui aime bien tout envoyer
donc évidemment que dans des six ne
prend pas que c'est pour défendre le
pion Michel il est pour t'envoyer tout
dans la gueule un Breton un Breton bien
sûr on les connaît
[Musique]
c'est clairement ce qu'il veut faire
voilà
bah écoute si j'avais beaucoup peut-être
qu'on peut commencer hein
tout à l'heure j'avais un peu du mal à y
croire Madame le côté
c'est un peu pour pour troller oui mais
bon en fait moi je pensais aussi à part
G6
[Musique]
pourquoi faire
pas grand-chose mais non mais je prends
ça ça toi
ça marche 4
tu peux être solidactif et là regarde
l'idée de Michel maintenant
et pourquoi pas un pistolet à liquide
sur la colonage
ça fait 250 parties que je joue en vrai
et j'ai jamais réussi à faire un
pistolet d'alikin sur l'échiquier
peut-être un jour j'y arriverai si c'est
contre vous
je pense que tu gagneras
je prendrai une photo désolé d'avance à
mon futur adversaire
[Musique]
c'est un peu trop flag et
je pense que moi ma théorie se vérifie à
l'IRESA avait pas vu que son cavalent G5
était en prise
[Rires]
et maintenant bon maintenant
il va falloir la récupérer
j'aime bien ce que fait Ariane tari
parce qu'en fait il continue à mettre la
pression sur le centre blanc
2 comme tu l'envisageais et tout revit
tout simplement je continue à menacer
des prises en des quatre ouvrir
ça pas de sens un peu plus la voiture de
là-bas et même un jour
moi je peux même pas ouvrir la fenêtre
chez moi c'est beaucoup trop bruyant et
il fait 35 degrés actuellement dans mon
bureau
de l'ouvrir donc c'est vrai que
ça dure après une minute ça va s'arrêter
et donc ouais donc là maintenant si je
prends là encore une fois on va manger
du théâtre
et on arrive à maintenir
ce pion isolé en dessin
d'ouvrir avec les Blancs
est-ce qu'on le fait c'est 4 pour mettre
notre cavale en D3 c'est une bonne
question
est-ce que les blancs peuvent faire
quelque chose contre ça peut-être
qu'elle va le 1 tout de suite pour lui
dire non non
et après je vais faire à trois et tu vas
tu vas aller ailleurs quoi
il y a toujours cette tension qui
demeure entre entre H5 et G6 ça fait
moins 10 coups
excuse-moi
je crois que je suis revenu et oui et ça
t'arrive je pense que ça le dérangerait
pas
ok bon on est parti chaud
on sait pas encore ce qui va faire
toutes les possibilités ouais il
t'arrive il joue avec du coeur ça on
peut pas lui enlever bah il profite
c'est pas tous les jours où il peut que
tu arrives c'est un super genre qu'elle
est noir ici qui a chemise blanche sur
la caméra c'est un joueur qui a
maintenant une vingtaine d'années je
dirais 24 ans
il a 2642 hello c'est un super joueur
c'est je pense le top 2
Norvège ouais top 2 ou 3 en Norvège
et donc c'est un super joueur mais
normalement avec avec son élo et ben il
n'a rien à faire pour moi comme celui-là
du monde on a quasiment que des joueurs
qui sont dans le top 10 mondial
quasiment et lui il doit être un peu en
top 100
c'est ce qu'on appelle la white card
voilà mais après c'est un tournoi dans
son pays et puis il a été invité par
l'organisation et puis là donc il est
très content d'être là
il peut se mesurer au meilleur joueur du
monde alors que normalement il a pas
trop trop l'occasion de les jouer et
donc il va profiter plus tard de tout ça
et
tout simplement
donner le meilleur de lui-même pour ce
tournoi là ouais je pense que c'est une
opportunité importante pour lui parce
que avant c'était plutôt Yonne luth Vig
Hammer l'autre norvégien qui est très
fort qui occupait cette place d'invité
et il a remplacé Hammer parce qu'il est
sans doute un peu plus prometteur que
lui un peu plus jeune globalement mais
il faudrait pas qu'il qu'il rate trop
son occase parce qu'il doit y avoir
quelques autres petits norvégiens qui
traînent derrière et qui pourrait assez
vite le remplacer
main à Paris non c'est la deuxième ou
troisième je crois mais il veut quand
même souvent quand il y a un tournoi qui
se joue
à domicile il est souvent là mais
avant c'est tout le temps
je crois qu'on peut avoir Google je
crois que c'est évident ah ouais mais
c'est cette grosse c’était une grosse
promesse il a été champion du monde
junior champion du monde junior c'est un
truc de fou il y a très peu de gens qui
ont réussi ça ah oui c'est fini
ça va être quand il a fait ceci
[Musique]
les turbos échangent
tout a disparu à la vitesse de la
lumière
OK
ils sont serrés à la main là je crois
ils sont deux ça fait nul
je pensais
que ici des blancs mettent à la pression
mais en fait je pense que tu me
réveilles
[Musique]
qui se soit dit bon allez flemme
bah ouais il fait pas un tournoi
formidable il a perdu hier entre entre
[Musique]
il avait
joué enfin je vais te dire il avait
perdu en Armageddon je crois
[Musique]
dans la partie longue
et voilà
un deuxième partie terminée on va avoir
15 minutes j'imagine
l'Armageddon entre ces deux joueurs là
ça peut être sympa ça peut être sympa
ok donc il nous reste trois parties il y
a eu un projet 5 chez Pirou et le reste
on a un peu en stand-by on va avoir une
partie de saut qu'on guérit qui va je
pense bientôt se terminer par la nul
aussi
ça améliore le fou de casse blanche
adverse en fait c'est de le prendre
[Musique]
à faire mais je pense pas il y a pas
cette pièce
ça
est-ce que on partirait pas pour une
petite pause sachant que d'ici 15
minutes je vois 16 minutes exactement on
va avoir le on va avoir l'armage gagnant
qui va commencer ouais juste avant
maintenant je réponds à la petite
question d'Exodus 49 Carlsen s'est
terminé il a fait une nulle très rapide
contre Nakamura et ensuite il l'a battu
en Armageddon et on se retrouve
doucement dans 5 10 minutes ouais 5
minutes
là on est on est parti il se passe pas
grand chose donc au moins ça nous permet
de revenir
[Musique]
5 minutes restez avec toi tout à l'heure
à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechesse
ou les title Tuesday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroulent en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition aux pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour monsieur Stéphane
Laborde avec nous sur le stream alors je
dis ça parce que sur
Youtube et bien il y a des gens qui
prennent Antoine pour Stéphane Laborde
on lit de ces choses et je pourrais
avoir l'âge d'être son fils un peu de
respect s'il vous plaît pour Stéphane
Laborde pas pour moi
ouais on repart tout de suite sur les
parties là si tu le veux bien j'ai vu
une ligne ah bah d'ailleurs il l'a pas
joué mais dans la partie so Guiri
[Musique]
l'Armageddon de de goûtech juste pour
m'informer la vraie commencé à 19h10
donc dans deux minutes on va voir la
marionnette
dans la partie so Guiri donc il a choisi
de jouer tour D8 mais sinon s'il avait
laissé la tour en C8
vous pouvez prendre à deux
enfin après pour 5 prises à deux et là
pour 7
et finalement c'est assez pénible à
défendre cette affaire à 5 par exemple
en fait les blancs vont gagner un pion
les blancs vont gagner un pion et
peut-être pousser là il y a peut-être
pousser quatre pour essayer d'échanger
et de faire une finale de tour
une petite pression mais c'est quand
même ça a l'air quand même assez
ambulance cette histoire je pense il a
choisi tour des 8 donc
on a un plan de plus là je te fais juste
3 maintenant
et après il y en a deux
[Applaudissements]
donc là au moins il y a un plan qui
permet
pas
je pense que tu peux manger
des dessins avec tempo un jour peut-être
le temps de le pas non mais bon
[Musique]
c'est pas plus solide
du Fou donc tu vas avoir un peu tu crées
un peu d'embouteillage un tour de 5
c'est pas la case de la tour OK
[Musique]
si vous voulez
avoir un petit un petit armage qui est
assis son adversaire avec impatience
dans les parties
[Musique]
donc chez Abdou avait un projet 5 tours
aussi
et jouer chez caravane
chez kerwana et il a bien mis son roi en
G2 comme tu l'envisageais
elle est bien cette position qui sont
qui sont chaudes et
Google qui va commencer bientôt sur leur
magazine
moi je moi je vois bien
[Musique]
nulle entre so et guéri et le reste
c'est pas j'ai lancé ma mégalope Google
moi je la mets sur
ma mais non non non non non
ça part sur de maradjoukais pour moi
je sais pas on va voir ça va être chaud
64 j'ai l'impression que c'est une
attaque personnelle dans le dans le chat
je vais faire semblant de ne pas avoir
vu ce message
[Rires]
on voit que tu as beaucoup d'amis dans
le chat c'est dur là j'en prends plein
la tronche j'avais pas prévu ça
c'est un conte de Samira
plusieurs comptes pour ce titre c'est
probable
Google qu'est-ce qui qui joue dans
l'avant il a trois pions déjà
sur la 3 sur la 5e avec les noirs
et donc 7 minutes KO pour les Noirs
contre 10 minutes KO pour les blancs
avec bien sûr un rajoutant de une
seconde parcours à partir de 40e
et
qu'est-ce qui se place un peu tous ces
pions sur case noire ça va rendre son
fou assez faible ce qui va sans doute
jouer avec D6 j'imagine et le four G7
va voir si le pion en désiste ou en
dessin mais vu ce qu'il a fait tous les
trous qu'il a fait je pense qu'il te
décide
pour pouvoir sur H5 fermé avec G5
[Musique]
après son Armageddon contre Paris que il
fallait de façon
il fallait tout envoyer
c'est ce qui fait encore une fois
avec son H4 là
donc D6 ca va avec les deux il va sur
ces cases là est-ce qu'on le fait pas F5
tout de suite là vous F5 voilà j'ai un
destin le replacement du cavale c'est
magnifique
dans le dans l'anglaise
d'ailleurs souvent on le fait avant de
troquer pas avoir cette tour mal placé
qui doivent bouger pour essayer etc
donc avaler des cinq
F5 a été joué
F4 logique on va essayer de bloquer un
petit peu les pièces noires en faisant
F4 qui m'intéresse ce qui m'interroge un
peu je me dis ok mais le roi est encore
assez ouvert de ce côté là ça me fait un
peu peur
mais après avoir
tourbé
du B5 en un seul coup ça me paraît
bizarre non ça va pas faire
ça peut pas vraiment essayer le coup
maintenant qu'il a fait F4 le coup H5
qui part ça veut tout ouvrir à le roi
mais il a jamais prévu de roquer dans
cette pose
ou alors vraiment sous la contrainte
ça fait réfléchir un peu le joueur
indien qui part avec 3 minutes de moins
que son adversaire je le rappelle
il faut que je le mette là
on est à 5 minutes 30 entre 8 et on
commençait à 7 contre 10 donc pour
l'instant il joue à la même vitesse mais
Google plus vite le début parce que faut
pas se mettre en diagnost je vous
rappelle que c'est du chaos
c'est du chaos quand même
donc H5 c'est intéressant maintenant
j'ai 5 deviens un peu impossible à jouer
salut Patou alors pas tout j'en profite
de te voir sur le chat parce que
aujourd'hui c'est un peu la joie
d'Antoine je crois que Antoine il a pris
cher un peu parler viewers qui sont ici
il y a plein de de moquerie aujourd'hui
contre
la tronche arrêtez et donc je profite de
ta de ta
ta aujourd'hui Fatou pour te rappeler je
pense très très bien mais il parait que
tu as battu notre ami Antoine en un parc
club il y a quelques quelques mois
j'ai pas de souvenir de cet incident
mais ok c'est sûrement un match du
couloir je crois en fin de partie il y
avait un truc comme ça je pense que
partie qui a qui a duré très très
longtemps si je ne m'abuse ah c'est pas
la même c'est pas la même non non c'est
pas la même c'est pas la même non non
j'en perd beaucoup tu sais c'est tout
[Rires]
ok donc bon je sais pas j'ai pas la
partie
en plus j'imagine que tu as du bien de
la noter cette partie et donc je te fais
confiance en toi même elle est pas mal
elle est pas mal la partie
on peut ouvrir une vidéo Fatou qui la
commande en direct pour être drôle
alors cavalier 7 donc c'est logique
d'essayer d'échanger un petit peu les
pièces contre la cadet 5 mais c'est vrai
que là j'aime bien les blancs parce que
j'ai l'impression que l'attaque elle est
un peu gratuite il est noir ont du mal à
se développer un je pense qu'on va faire
un petit grand rock là des cinq veines
tu rajoutes
comme la case plein de fois donc le
contrôle de noir alors difficile à
choper là il y a une découverte
attention il va bouger la dame
arrive à activer son full case noir là
ça sera trop enfin une pièce de trop et
les Noirs vont se rentrer dedans pour
l'instant il fait rien il est derrière
la structure mais s'il arrive un jour à
passer je ne sais comment ça deviendra
intenable
tout le monde à la fois
c'est le problème et surtout on prend
des 5 et ben c'est un peu la même chose
mais il y a prise de tête en premier il
y a pas prise de cette en premier
sur échec et après tu prends le 5 un
truc comme ça et comme ça
[Musique]
on en a parlé plusieurs fois sur le
stream
mais Antoine Antoine est
assez fair-play il disait que tu avais
très bien joué et
[Musique]
mais bon ça c'est pas de police E4
ouais c'était pour être poli j'étais
surtout en gueule de bois
non non vraiment bien joué c'était une
belle partie en plus il y a des parties
qu'on déteste perdre d'autres ça va ça
va
je te dis que si moi je perds
mais non mais moi j'ai le même hello
quel c'est pas pareil oui moi je peux
pas
te permettre
niveau troll ma vie est terminée ma
carrière est terminée juste c'est c'est
je peux pas il y a des gens
tu peux pas voilà
plein plein de choses à faire c'est très
compliqué il est en train de s'en sortir
là il est en train de s'en sortir bon là
après ma mec a quand même son attaque
furieuse là sur la colonne h ça fait mal
j'ai peur il faut trouver un
retrouver
aussi ici il a fait full le site pour
F5 mais bon c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué à après c'est compliqué
pour personne
[Rires]
ne t'inquiète pas pour ça j'ai plutôt un
bon un bon record contre stouf je crois
que c'est un zéro pour moi
on est sur on est sur ma média Rohff ok
parce que il me semble qu'on avait
ensemble
dans mes souvenirs
je me trompe peut-être attention
comme pas possible
en fait j'ai une stats qui est amusante
ma meilleure partie sur chelse.com ma
meilleure victoire c'était toi donc
voilà ça se passait facile de me
rappeler en fait
et là il y a du via du Fou des 5 qui
arrive aussi c'est un vrai échec parce
que le Roi peut pas se réfugier en F6 il
y a plein plein de choses mais le roi
blanc est aussi mal placé en terme D3
c'est un coup
attention comment est-ce que je peux
c'est pas une menace malheureusement
d'un prank elle va les prendre je reste
clouer ici j'ai envie de jouer fouter 5
quand même alors
je ferai
je ferai j'ai 5 j'ai 4
ouais mais en fait tu es un peu lent
dans le sens
à une découverte mais je vois pas de
découverte
c'est très très chaud là les Noirs vont
s'arrêter mais s'ils sont pas matés
attention alors roi c'est hyper chaud
attention
il est dans une salle situation et la
jauge qui disait zéro évidemment
c'est hyper compliqué 4 minutes pour les
blancs contre 2 minutes pour les noirs
du chaos pendant encore 13 coups quand
la jauge dit zéro position aussi Dingo
c'est évidemment qu'elle voit que
l'ordinateur voit une perpétuel quelque
part sur le chemin
un échec perpétuel une répétition forcée
moi j'aime toujours bien fou des cinq
j'ai l'impression que cavaluer
[Musique]
pour les Noirs après dame aussi
incroyable
de
c'est compliqué
la jauge qui vient de la jauge qui vient
de plonger dans les abysses avec la
ligne qu'on vient de voir littéralement
et Mamer pourtant il a pris son temps
pour calculer ça mais il a pris deux
minutes c'est pas rien 2 minutes pour un
joueur de talent et là il va se faire
mater en fait à l'ancienne par le jeune
prodige
pour comprendre
la dépense
pour faire ça pour pas qu'il y ait
chacun
va cavale 2 tu as il a payé la cavalue
OK
Descartes
très très chaud mais du coup dame 6
n'est plus possible maintenant il y a un
problème sur ça sur ça sur ça sur ça il
y a 30 000 échecs et là
des perpettes avec l'âme G7 peut-être
pour commencer
[Musique]
2 minutes contre une 20 une 30 quasiment
c'est ultra bruyant cette position
et ça va
ça va faire nul la répétition
ça n'a pas d'intérêt donc
il y a pas d'autre coup en fait là il va
se faire mater
contre le matin en E2 ouais mais bon
j'ai l'impression que ce que mate quand
même de partout enfin j'ai dû tourner
deux
il a le seul là
il a pris en C4 ouais bah c'est parce
qu'il veut pas
ça fait beaucoup là
pour avoir une seconde d'incrément donc
là ça appartient dans tous les sens
quand vous allez voir un Pokémon assez
les blancs sont obligés de faire un
parpattuelle j'ai pas assez de pièces
sur ma tête la tour elle est trop loin
le cavalier il est cloué et j'ai deux
pièces pour pour attaquer quoi même si
c'est 5 super mais
il est drôlement bon ce jeune goûter il
a retourné cette pause comme un boss
voilà ça a perdu là malheureusement
très content de répéter cette pause ok
je peux plus perdre
un moment qu'il a compris je pense oui
il a compris dès qu'il s'est pris en
fait le après son coup de fou D5
il s'est pris le très méchant
il s'est pris le très très méchant tout
en fait non dames 3 quand il y avait
trois échec là il a dû dire oh là mais
en fait c'est grave
il continue à brosser 5
il vendait
aucun jeu et il sait que la nul
il apprend la
Google
pour avoir la crème
soit 39e tous les deux
pour la crème d'une seconde après c'est
pas grand chose quand même c'est pas
grand chose mais ça permet de pas tomber
c'est bon maintenant les joueurs ont une
seconde d'incrément à chaque coup depuis
un coup
par quelle magie va il va mater dans
cette
[Musique]
parce que je mets cavalier en D4
encore plus forts
des couches chelous mais il va jamais
arrêter de jouer
[Musique]
le panache du jeune bouquet
moi je ferai un coup comme tour ces deux
ici
c'est hyper hyper chaud allez il faut
jouer là il cherche l'accident en fait
il cherche l'accident
tout à fait
un message un message raisonnable
énorme partie en tout cas des deux
joueurs un gros gros spectacle et bravo
en tout cas à Google
voir un peu les parties voir un peu ce
qui s'est passé et cinq c'était une
sacrée idée de sa part parce qu'il était
en train de commencer à se faire
attaquer la tronche sur le roi et il a
envoyé B5 il a tout ouvert pendant que
le roi de Mamé était au centre et waouh
ça c'est drôlement bien passé pour lui
[Musique]
il s'est passé des choses quand même on
va aller voir un peu ce qui s'est passé
on s'est arrêté
par prendre de la dame après 13 minutes
de réflexion voilà qui avait un vrai
dilemme pour les raisins
le tour aussi de Michel voilà est-ce
qu'on peut
aussi un coup qui fallait jouer à un
moment donné parce que là on peut
s'imaginer qu'après dame 2 il était des
blancs c'est parfois 6 pour échanger les
pièces défensives des noirs et après
aller capturer tous les trucs et tu as
vu sur C5 prise il a fait des cas tout
de suite
prise D4 ok là c'est pas étonnant
parce qu'il veut il veut jouer actif il
a compris que positionnellement il avait
une position qui craignait un peu pour
ces faiblesses là et donc il joue
dynamique donc ça il a tenté le matin
d'un coup ici que ce serait sûrement
pris et il avait de la musique 4
après dame j'ai 4 qui a eu dame 7
parce que bien sûr là on joue pour
l'initiative on va pas changer les dames
maintenant ça serait un petit peu
dommage et on garde la pression
d'ailleurs sur l'option 3 voilà c'est
hyper compliqué
c'est malheureusement le fou pour
l'instant est ici et sinon ça pourrait
être sympa de faire tourner essayer
de retard castor dit c'est joli la
structure là c'est incroyable cette
diagonale avec des pions de couleur
différente sur c'est impuissance 4 A2
ouais c'est hyper chaud
qu'est-ce qu'on prend est-ce qu'on prend
E3 est-ce qu'on prend c'est ça qu'est-ce
qu'on comprend rien
alors
pardon
alors là j'ai deux choses je peux manger
soit en B6 sont en C5 d'ailleurs j'aime
bien que c'est 5 implants que j'attaque
là et là
l'impression que ça gagne du matériel
pour moi
[Musique]
on les élimine il reste encore il reste
ici
[Musique]
on prend des 6
S
toutes les cases blanches avec le 5
ouais c'est Paris soit tu prends les
câbles blanches tu prends le pion
c'est toi qui vois donc il faut vraiment
bien
juger la position là il faut que je
vienne de force donc
la dame qui revient en G5 mais est-ce
que je peux pas jouer ça maintenant
avec un pack double ici alors la jauge a
l'air de surkiffer cette position
parce que je défends pas comme ça
[Musique]
c'est dur
je pense la vraie menace c'est qu'elle
va le 5 dans cette
ça a l'air fort
on a l'impression qu'on va récupérer le
pion avec initiative et si c'est le cas
et ben écoute c'est difficile en fait
que c'est le moment de commencer à
échanger quelques pièces
est-ce que vous F5 pourrait être un coup
dire que alors j'avais oublié que je
l'avais je n'aime pas
et si je vous fais F5 et que tu bouges
ta tour
et ben je mange là et après je pourrais
tranquillement te manger
c'est pas la solution un problème et si
je bouge pas
[Musique]
peut-être c'est ce que je regarde là
prise des quatre je pensais je pensais à
ça mais là
intéressant dans le sens que je vais
manger je vais récupérer de matériel et
puis j'ai souvent ceci c'est pas un
petit bouge de cavalier
je peux manger là et avoir ces 6
derrière et avoir des cinq barrières et
avoir carrément V6 et ça peut très vite
tourner quoi mais en fait je crois que
le problème
remettez moi votre arme monsieur souffle
là vous êtes visiblement intoxiqué c'est
trop là non mais bon ça pourrait être
une idée mais non un peu trop pas tout
match donc là j'ai bougé ma dame quelque
part je sais pas encore où il y a ça en
prise et juste là et je te dis
un problème sur la dame
des trois maintenant tu prends madame je
prends la tienne
qui reste en l'air à la fin
ouais non complexe
tous les jours tous les jours il se met
des dingueries hier contre mamie c'était
assez incroyable
[Musique]
il y a une menace très concrète ça fait
un truc très concret et après il y a
tous ces tensions de pions c'est super
compliqué à gérer les Noirs ont
peut-être un plan plus clair ils ont
super diagonal pour leur
c'est chaud qu'est-ce qui se passe
carwana ici Caravana contre Paris il y a
eu beaucoup de coups de jouets on s'est
arrêté à roi F1 je crois pour C8 car
wanna il va piano comme on avait dit il
a il avance avec son petit avantage là
il est bien il est bien
écoute il a évité tous les problèmes
tactiques que vous voulez lui causer
tari au centre il a tout stabilisé et
maintenant son petit avantage c'est que
l'autre a un peu isolé voilà on peut
peut-être imaginer un cavalier de
cavaliers F4 et doubler sur la colonne D
et que les tours et taper là dessus mais
c'est pas si facile parce que dès que
les Noirs l'occasion
[Musique]
mais après tu as un plan isolé
peut-être pas de suite mais
c'est souvent une idée dans cette partie
j'aurais quand même j'aurais dû dame
j'aurais dû dommage 5 encore sur G5
[Musique]
si Paris arrive à la défendre mais ça va
pas être une partie de plaisir le plan
de 5
il veut se faire grinder là par karwana
là il va passer un quart d'heure le
pauvre norvégien
je suis d'accord voilà ce qu'on a la
dernière partie à voir de saut entre
Aniche
[Musique]
ouais bon celle-là
ah maintenant la niche qui aimerait
échanger
il a remis son
il a remis sa tour en eux
il se dit bon bah c'est un 4 contre 4
finalement
envie de manger parce que ça ferait une
belle chaîne de pion avec un plan passé
ici pour les blancs
je pense que ce qui va essayer de faire
TF10
mais ça va faire nul je pense sans trop
trop de problèmes ici pour pour les pour
les noirs
qui essaient de
jouer pour la nul mais ça va faire nulle
facile je pense
comment est-ce que je peux empêcher F6
peut-être bouger le roi mais tu vas même
sur un truc comme ça la Game 6 je peux
même jouer maintenant
[Musique]
et on a cette offre et firu Jack en fait
qui se livre à un combat sans merci
et je pense que c'est peut-être la
partie à suivre
en priorité de 1 parce que c'est votre
français qui joue ici actuellement
à l'irréda et de deux parce que c'est la
partie qui est la plus folle
alors quand les autres il se passe pas
grand chose je pense que
[Musique]
so Wesley girus
un Armageddon et Paris et ben ça joue
encore c'est encore plein de pièces il a
grindé le petit pion isolé et ici il
faut quand même commencer à regarder un
peu ce qui se passe concrètement parce
que par rapport à ce qu'on a calculé
est-ce qu'on a montré il y a quelques
minutes on menace Caval pro C5 on menace
plein de choses et le problème du Fou en
prise ici avec un aussi un vis-à-vis etc
par rapport à tout ce qu'on a énoncé et
ben on avait dit que le fouet F5 avait
l'air obligatoire
maintenant tu repos F5 on pouvait bouger
la tour et essayer de faire des échanges
pour gagner le 6 pour être lié des
blancs le problème ici c'est que je peux
jouer peut-être
avec les Noirs Cavalo 5 en intermédiaire
mais je crois que
là on avait dit tout au F6 il me semble
est-ce que j'ai pas
[Musique]
en premier peut-être avant de faire F5
ici
dans ce cas
Ier prend
dans ce cas je crois
c'est 4
OK
peut-être prise des 4
ça a l'air pas mal ça ça
te fatiguer là comment ça va
non mais l'idée en fait
j'y croyais pas trop mais l'idée avec la
fin c'était pas si horrible non c'est
clair d'abord d'un F4 pour s'enlever de
la fourchette et puis tu vas mettre ton
four dans ces quatre quand les Noirs
prennent dans ces 5 tu reprends bon
en fait c'est de normaliser la fin de
stabiliser la position côté blanc parce
que là sinon
ça peut prendre feu assez vite
donc c'est le coup qu'on regardait et
quel est le 5 à chaque fois qu'on
mettait l'ordinateur parce que
j'ai craqué je viens de lancer le lancer
l'ordi qu'avale le 5 il aime à cause de
dame G3
c'est que
sur ça
comme seul coup pour aller Raisa
l'ordi donne ça comme seul coup pour
rester dans la partie en fait ça c'est
waouh c'est tendu enfin comme hier
contre Mamée il avait il a trouvé des
séries de seul coup
apparemment foue F5 était le seul coup
et la cavalier le seul coup ouais
je crois que ça va être une répétition
en fait apparemment
si j'en crois l'ordinateur les gens ont
pas le choix que de répéter la nul
tout ressenti peut être joué pour 5 et 6
après avoir envie
les mecs jouent à un niveau
stratosphérique c'est pas impossible que
ça fasse nul
c'est pas un peu mieux
pas possible
et c'est mieux que j'avais pas du tout
du tout vu alors mon élogey
tu vas te noircir à force d'en parler
ça a mal se passer je suis à 2399
avec plein plein de normes de mi
il serait temps que je fasse 2400 hello
j'ai ma première à ma prochaine partie
qui va te jouer le 16 juin faire un
tournoi pour les jours à moins de 2400
hello et c'est un open tranquille chez
moi bon il y a quand même un beau
plateau il y a quand même plusieurs il y
a plein de mètres
mais voilà en fait je gagne la première
partie juste la première et bien c'est
fait et la première partie normalement
je vais jouer un 1500 1600 euros
donc
3e en 2016 donc
il a trouvé la Cavalaire
et apparemment c'est c'est nul forceur
si je fais pas dame là ou damla si je
vais ailleurs ça il y a peut-être du G5
et Madame elle peut être enfermée non
bah je te prends ici si tu me l'enferme
comment
tu pouvais m'en faire ma commande
j'ai commencé à regarder un peu plus là
fais gaffe si tu oublies ça contre un
1600 à Valence
la grosse célébration de 1500 il va pas
comprendre
pourquoi le si content de te battre
je crois que c'est de la partie de ma
vie contre 1500 €
en 2016 la troisième norme j'avais 2300
42 je crois après la troisième norme et
je suis passé rapidement en 80 par là et
depuis 2016-2017 je suis à 2380 je mets
tous les vélos à 80 81 82 85 84 79
je suis capable de faire des bons
tournois et de faire plein de normes
comme tu l'as vu j'en ai cinq
de bien jouer quand je suis en forme
mais je suis capable de perdre 50 points
sur un tournoi quand je commence mal ce
qui était j'arrive plus
la morale un petit peu voilà un moral
d'acier
mais quand je commence
mais maintenant que tu sais je donne des
cours je suis entraîneur je ne me
parlais pas
parce que c'est pas bien c'est pas
fair-play sauf que c'était malade etc
ça soit d'abord si ça te fait plaisir
d'être là faut pas se forcer non non
mais après normalement quand tu signe
pour un tournoi c'est parce que tu fais
le tourner en entier donc au niveau des
organisateurs comme ça ça m'a l'air bien
jusqu'au bout et
quand tu signes tu sais pas comment tu
vas jouer mais tu vas le trou ou quoi
enfin en tout cas c'est un peu ce que
j'essaie de de
d'inculter à mes élèves à tout ça donc
il faut que je vous montre aussi
l'exemple et que le soir comme ça même
quand je fais pour moi jusqu'au bout et
des fois c'est pas facile ce qui est
très nul c'est ne le faites pas c'est
partir du tournoi sans avoir prévenu
l'arbitre ça c'est vraiment très nul
ça m'est arrivé deux fois de me pointer
le dernier jour j'avais pas l'adversaire
mais évidemment j'ai prévenu l'arbitre
la veille enfin c'est la moindre des
choses
ça m'est arrivé aussi
mais quand j'étais plus jeune et que je
me foutais un peu plus
mais maintenant maintenant je vais
jusqu'au bout quand je m'inscris je sais
que je vais faire toutes les parties
moi aussi normalement c'est juste que si
c'est pas loin de chez moi et que tu
passes vraiment trop mal moi je suis un
amateur voilà je suis pas là pour me
faire du mal quoi ça m'est arrivé une
seule fois j'étais à 100 bornes de chez
moi je suis allé je vais plutôt prendre
le train là parce que je joue vraiment
trop mal
je pense que j'ai bien fait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'ailleurs avec
cette dame côté côté
comme ça et la dame elle a mal placé je
pense que c'est mieux de faire download
damla j'aimerais bien E3 E4 enfin du
détroit de 2 qui peuvent arriver
j'aimerais la mettre j'ai trois pour
pouvoir pousser F3 et protéger la tour
E1 deux fois et pouvoir prendre des
quatre
je vais la mettre en G3 pour pouvoir un
jour faire F3 et prendre en D4
protégeant ma tour E
iffel
non c'est trop long mais au moins au
moins je commence à proposer ce genre
d'idée donc
je fais nul
le problème c'est que est-ce que les
raisins va vouloir faire mieux
c'est pas trop le genre de la maison non
mais bon ok la position
et guéri je les vois à la caméra qui ont
fait nul
mais ça c'était pas une surprise ça fait
un moment qu'on avait dit que ça allait
sûrement très très vite sur un nul je
roule là de voir la fin rapidement
il avait le droit fuite
et répétitions comme ça ok bon nul c'est
assez logique de la part des deux
joueurs
assez grand chose dans cette partie
donc l'armée donc il va on va être
averti bientôt de l'horaire de l'armée
un petit peu à grinder
donc je crois qu'il y a eu ce qu'on
avait dit on est trois fois je crois
Antoine
hop maintenant pour ça caille F4 c'est
la partie ouais j'ai cinq pas possible à
cause des choses sur la case H5 et là on
a mis tout le monde sur la 4D5 on a vu
tout le monde sur le plan d'être 5
donc je suis quand même quatre fois
dessus et que deux fois donc a priori le
pion est gagné on a dit que j'ai 5
est-ce que
ça serait pas le moment de le rendre par
des quatre justement
le donner
un petit peu posé problème parce qu'en
fait il y a plusieurs tactiques qui
arrivent de 1 en faisant un 4 et bien je
vis je viens plateau et après j'ai la
case des sons qui peut venir pour mon
cavalier je pourrais profiter pour
manger ce fond en F6 et continuer à
attaquer ton roi
ok on a le temps
[Musique]
si tu le veux bien T4
bah si sur D4
il dit j'ai
400 ok ok maintenant c'est filou
typique de la position on veut essayer
de rendre ce pion moi je voyais aussi ça
pour essayer de de d'enlever l'attaquant
c'est le seul coup d'après l'ordinateur
tu vois il y a du G4 dans MH3 il y a
plein de choses ça a l'air franchement
difficile pour les Noirs donc il leur
reste 22 minutes pour les noirs pour
jouer 17 coups donc 22 minutes chaos
pour Jeudi 7 coups et obtenir les 10
secondes par coup alors tu imagines que
même si
j'arrive au 40ème coup avec à la pendule
à la pendule ben j'arrive avec une
minute plus 10 qu'on parcours donc c'est
franchement rien du tout non c'est
terrible c'est trop trop peu et comme tu
viens de le dire le coup que tu viens de
donner à la foufou c'est 3 c'est qui qui
permet après de rester vivant dans cette
pause et on a vu hier karian avec peu de
temps il a raté il a raté les coups
comme ça Ariane je crois que le le
[Musique]
blitzer 3 B prend là je pense à cavalier
5 ou à cavalier le 7 il y a un coup
actif l'autre qui est moins actif et sur
un cavaluation qu'il faut il faut
commencer à penser aussi à des coups
comme d'hab prendre exemple mesdames
mais après je parlerai 7 mois donc
je me dis que la tour en plus en F5 elle
a un petit peu enfermée tu vois je sais
pas s'il y a moyen d'aller enfermer
pas de suite mais le regard là j'en
aurai une idée
fourchette
ok ok ok désolé les gens désolé comment
ça fatigué clairement là ça fait trois
jours on fait ça quand même
trouvé une idée sympa parce que la tour
le pion à 7 et la fourchette
ce n'est pas mal mais non il y a au goût
qui nous dit qu'il suit pas trop les
compètes d'échec comment ça marche alors
là c'est simple il y a 10 il y a 10
joueurs ils vont tous s'affronter donc
ils font en tout neuf rondes et ça les
affrontent tous les autres c'est comme
une grosse poule chaque jour il joue une
partie à celle longue où ils ont deux
heures chacun
s'il y en a un qui l'a gagné il gagne 3
points comme au foot l'autre gagne 0
s'il faut match nul comme au foot aussi
marque un point chacun mais ensuite il
faut une partie beaucoup plus rapide il
refroidi beaucoup plus rapide et là
celui qui la gagne un demi point bonus
globalement ça fait un petit championnat
en fait de 9 parties de 9 rondes on
appelle ça des rondes aux échecs et à la
fin de ces 9 rondes bah généralement il
y a peut-être des égalités mais souvent
il y a un joueur qui s'est détaché en
tête qui gagne le tournoi
voilà comment ça marche un tournoi
d'échec fermé
et donc là ce tournoi il a un peu
spécial parce que les tournois avec
Armageddon direct même les cadences
enfin les cadences de ce tournoi sont un
peu spécial là vous voyez les points et
carou 1 contre Magnus Carlson 1,5
nul donc ça fait un point un match nul
et Margus qui a gagné l'Armageddon qui a
gagné un demi point de plus normalement
dans les vrais championnats une nul
c'est 0,5
et une défaite C0 et un gars c'est un
point là le gain c'est trois points la
nul c'est un point mais l'Armageddon ça
fait un demi point en plus donc en fait
là c'est un tournoi un peu spécial c'est
pas vraiment
un bon exemple si vous voulez de
oups
ou c'est juste un point la victoire un
demi point le match nul et 0 on la
défaite c'est le
la manière la plus fréquente de faire
les tournois d'échec et il y a l'ami
Ariane ça y est il nous a gaffé parce
que la jauge d'évaluation vient de faire
un bon vers le ciel
il a joué dame
pas vraiment parce que je peux encore
manger là mais peut-être qu'il espère
faire un truc comme ça avec du cavalier
5 étant C3
n'est pas possible
non effectivement
trouver sur un petit gros tournoi c'est
super agréable merci à toi purokaï merci
beaucoup pour tes petits mots plaisir de
te voir parmi nous carrément j'ai pas
trop regardé ce qui se passe sur
Youtube salut est-ce que Ali resa a
encore joué avec le feu ou bien c'est
une partie maîtriser
c'était maîtrisé
sans vos parents je suis le saski qui
soit très créatif
des choses il s'est passé des trucs et
ici des joueurs n'ont pas voulu faire un
nul on avait vu avec l'ordinateur qui
avait une proposition de nul possible
avec cavalier 6 et
dame G3 d'un f4p les seuls coups pour
des blancs pour maintenant l'égalité et
apparemment la nul ce il est revenu
en E2 il y a vraiment en fin de
l'histoire
prend ces 6 doit être joué
[Musique]
ouais mais pourquoi vous pouvez pas
continuer à garder de l'attention
je crois que c'était OK
embêtant le fou en fait
[Musique]
non non les Noirs attaque en fait ils
prennent en E3 et commencer à attaquer
il faut un pion faible de
ok c'est si je comprends je comprends
donc si si ça a été joué et puis bah
écoute c'est compliqué là
on s'attend à une finale peut-être
ce type là
qui peut être faible c'est pas égalité
il y a un pion pour les blancs
pour les blancs c'est un vrai pion
avec le noir
qui traînent ou pas pour les noirs
cette variante au lieu de prendre trois
attends on fait les coups dans l'ordre
tour prend F5
intermédiaire
est-ce que avant de prendre le four ah
non parce que justement le fou contrôle
la casse des trois donc il prendra des
trois ok
10 + 40ème coup alors en fait au goût
rapidement que tu ne sont pas du tout au
contraire on aime beaucoup interagir
avec le chat donc n'hésite pas à des
questions alors qu'avant c'était 120 +
10 au 40e coup en fait
120 c'est les minutes donc on a deux
heures pour toute la partie chacun voilà
chacun et au 40e coup les joueurs vont
obtenir 10 secondes par coup jouer
à partir du 40e ce qui veut dire que là
ils ont deux heures tous les deux pour
toute la partie et après et voilà si tu
joues moins de 40 coups et que tes deux
heures s'écoule tu as perdu la partie
c'est terminé après si tu passes le 40e
tu as pendule remontera un peu si tu
joues très vite si tu joues tous tes
coups en moins de 10 secondes tu as
pendule va remonter un peu mais ça va
pas permettre de temps non plus donc
c'est joueurs là commencent à là tu vois
à l'IRISA et le reste 36 minutes de dire
Beck tout ça te ref il lui reste 24
minutes et c'est tout ce qui leur reste
pour jouer la partie on sait à réfléchir
[Musique]
peut-être des portes de sortie dans
cette position dépend le 3 il faut
prendre aussi de Michel
je vais prendre Michel là
OK
par contre par contre parce que je peux
pas manger c'est si manger le 3 parce
qu'à ce moment là j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a plus personne qui défend la
tour 1 et là peut-être un truc
tu as le fou en prise et ça en prise si
je bouge mon fou je vais avoir prise
échec d'un point est au programme
je sais pas je suis un fou non mais
avant de prendre
trois moi je pense à ça maintenant que
la tour défend plus ici je pense à ça
F3 maintenant que le fou va tomber de
toute façon
avec Madame
ok non mais là j'ai pas de purement
oui oui c'est sûr mais c'est pas si
dangereux pour les blancs
[Musique]
quand même
Abdou qui prend des risques dans cette
partie quand même
je viens de passer 300 élo en 5 minutes
loin de ce niveau là ouais bon après on
va tous commencer comme ça Simon tu
crois qu'on était champion du monde
enfin comme Magnus par exemple champion
du monde comme ça
c'était quoi ton premier élo stuff
c'est bon
j'ai commencé tout moi c'était 1500 ah
oui non
il a pris en C6 Lamia elle est c'est un
coup brillant oui tu as commencé gamin
toi évidemment comme tous
et donc oui j'ai mis 9 hein
mais c'est 1000 09 c'est les lots qu'on
te donne quand tu as jamais
donc je commençais à ça c'est pas
vraiment un élo ça c'est un élo de non
classé mon vrai hello classé je sais
plus du tout mais souvent les enfants
souvent les enfants ils commencent à
jouer des parties contre d'autres
enfants et très peu sont classés et en
fait ils ont du mal à obtenir un premier
classement et même quand tu commences
sur tous les autres au tout début tiens
c'est la partie
et maintenant est-ce qu'il va faire
froid
quand j'ai commencé en fait moi je fais
un petit peu long à la détente
mais oui non j'étais pas très bon donc
je suis pas du tout une référence chez
les amis j'ai
passé très je pense que les 1500 €
[Musique]
je vais être
pipi
[Musique]
et j'ai commencé tôt mais je suis resté
longtemps à 1200 1300
et des cours et tout enfin tu vois mais
juste que j'ai
je sais pas
mais c'est que plus tard moi j'ai
commencé à progresser vraiment vers
minimes vers minimes donc vers 15-16 ans
je suis passé je crois que je suis passé
2000 à 15 ans
et 2002 a peut-être à 16 17 ans
et 2003 en fait j'ai commencé à
progresser vite à cet âge là mais avant
minuit j'étais là mais
je pense que j'étais pas si imperfecteur
pour les échecs en fait si
j'avais beaucoup enfin j'avais très très
bon ami qui joue beaucoup d'échecs
là que j'ai commencé à vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup jouer à faire le tournoi à
partir un peu et tout mais avant ça je
pense que je vais plus parce que ben
parce que c'était comme ça en fait tu
vois à la base c'est mon frère qui joue
aux échec
et moi j'ai continué mais après je sens
que j'étais là mais un peu par défaut
enfin
je m'en foutais quoi je m'en fous
mais bon
tu t'en sors pas mal pour un mec qui a
commencé un peu à l'arrache comme ça
Michel nous envoie des variantes de ouf
alors les Noirs mieux d'après la joue
ouais c'est pareil
pour ça je pense
ok ok bon il faut calculer quand même
parce que je l'avais pas du tout vu
effectivement
et bon là ça a l'air quand même écrasant
parce que je sens l'air quand même d'un
B5 j'ai encore ça en l'air à manger
là-haut mais tout simplement en fait
effectivement les noirs sont un peu
mieux parce que le pion E3 va être isolé
je pense que Abdou va tout simplement
faire trois là
clairement
bref et ah ouais non mais c'est kata il
y a autour des deux qui arrivent
[Musique]
j'adore bon j'habite en Espagne aussi
maintenant c'est très facile et il y en
a très très bon c'est vrai que
[Musique]
en Argentine j'arrivais pas en trouver
quoi enfin pas
et par contre en Espagne c'est vrai que
c'est assez c'est assez cool mais quand
j'étais petit j'étais très difficile
pour manger et c'est encore
mais je me suis vachement amélioré quand
même et quand j'étais petit
soir et à samedi soir je rentrais
j'avais mes pizzas faite maison trop
bien et
quand j'étais petit la pizza je l'ai
mangé juste la pâte
elle me faisait une pâte
il y avait pas de tomates
j'ai même pas je n'ai rien
[Rires]
mais non je me suis vachement ignorer
maintenant je mange une pizza à 4
fromages
en fait je mange tout sauf ananas
ça c'est un truc qui est vraiment je
peux pas
c'est trop quoi chose que je ne peux pas
du tout alors que l'Armageddon de Sceaux
débute est-ce que tu veux aller voir
l'appariement l'Armageddon est-ce que tu
veux qu'on reste un peu sur ça juste
avant on peut regarder vite fait Fabiano
il y avait pris ces trois prises C3 dg5
et en fait alors là la joue j'ai en
train festoyer sur la position de
carwana après le coup dame 7 bah en fait
il a il a pris des cinq il a gagné 5 je
voulais mettre mon cavalier mettre mes
pions ici et puis ça va c'est un gros
pion et taré dans la sauce et
effectivement maintenant on peut aller
regarder cette petite armée est donc
allez on part par contre sur la main de
saut et
[Musique]
c'est pas la bonne cette vague je
voulais
et ça va commencer dans un instant
alors que penses-tu de cette partie
est-ce que tu aurais
une prédiction à nous donner
pièces sur guéri pièce sur guéri bien
sûr guéri bon écoute je suis obligé de
parier somme par contre je suis pas fan
de sommet
mais on est obligé OK
10 minutes contre 7 il joue un système
assez collant là tu vois
où il va sortir ses pièces tout
doucement je pense qu'il va mettre un
chien Ketto foot case noir peut-être non
pas du tout
ailleurs hier soir après sa défaite en
Armageddon contre quinzaine
[Musique]
il n'arrivait pas à s'adapter au Blitz
après avoir fait des parties
aussi pour cette fait complètement
retourné le cerveau par Magnus mais
après c'est vrai que psychologiquement
sauce c'est pas le meilleur des joueurs
du circuit
et donc je le crois bien je veux bien me
croire pour le coup
c'est ça que c'est vachement bien ça
tout de suite
donc là les noirs qui sont emparés de du
centre directement avec les Noirs j'aime
déjà mieux la position du Hollandais là
aussi j'aime pas trop généralement
laisser un truc en F4 il a deux coups
mais c'est un truc qui me plaît pas plus
que ça
donc faut 3 a été joué alors ici vu que
j'ai le coup de casse blanche
tout ça j'ai envie alors je sais pas
mais j'ai envie de bien je C4 pour bien
emmurer ton case noir qui est de fou que
je n'ai pas
par exemple ça et si un jour c'est pour
B5 donc préparer des 5 et tout et si
possible changer les fulcas dans
chansons etc et jouer contre ce fou ces
quatre étaient joués merci Guy de
m'écouter
je suis content ça y est ma journée
avec des femmes aussi ouais c'est
dommage d'ailleurs qu'il est tourné pour
les filles et les très bien ensemble les
garçons et les filles aux échecs
ça se fait de plus en plus maintenant
bientôt il y aura plus de tournoi pour
les filles je pense
qu'est-ce que tu en penses de ça
[Musique]
non je pense pas
non qu'est-ce que toi tu en penses je
veux dire je te demande pas un pronostic
je te demande un avis
sur la question bah il y a plus de bah
déjà il y a plus de d'hommes que de
femmes qui jouait le chèque là c'est une
évidence et le niveau des femmes ben oui
c'est vrai que quand on regarde le top
mondial la numéro 1 féminine elle est en
top 100 quoi
mixte donc quand tu fais un tournoi
fermé avec tous les meilleurs joueurs du
monde c'est un peu normal que des moins
de femmes parce que c'est les hommes
sont plus forts mais après bon il y a
beaucoup de tournant féminin aussi et il
y a quand même pas mal de temps au Pen
où les femmes ont bien sûr le droit de
participer etc
mais qu'est-ce que je voulais dire
qu'est-ce que tu penses des tournois
féminins c'est ça que bah en fait
question compliquée c'est un débat
compliqué aussi
je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de femmes qui
veulent pas jouer avec les femmes et qui
veulent jouer avec les hommes parce
qu'elle considère que ben il y a plus de
moyens de progresser avec les hommes qui
sont plus fortes etc que mettre dans la
féminin
comment dire il y a plein de femmes qui
sont pas forcément à l'aise de jouer
avec les femmes voilà après il y a
d'autres femmes aussi qui veulent femmes
et qui veulent plus jouer avec avec les
femmes qu'avec les hommes donc il y a un
petit peu tout moi mon avis sur la
question
bah écoute j'en ai pas vraiment
moi j'ai toujours respecté un peu tout
ça je sais pas trop d'avis sur la
question
t'es pas obligé de répondre tu m'as mis
non mais en fait
à l'époque par exemple toujours
maintenant et ben on a les championnats
par exemple pour se qualifier sur
platefrance et ben les pandas sont
séparés on avait mineur
mais en fait comme ça c'est pour ça
qu'on ne voit pas mais ça on va comment
je dois pas mal parce que ça tourne
comme ça il faut que ça change il est
temps que ça change mais du coup
il y a des filles qui voulaient jeter
les garçons et qui le peuvent
d'autres filles qui chaque année se
qualifient trop facilement je peux la
France parce que en plus elles sont pas
assez dans catégorie que niveau et moins
fort etc mais oui et puis c'est passé
incroyable que des gamins on les fasse
pas jouer ensemble si on fait pas jouer
les gamins ensemble jamais les adultes
jamais les filles seront aussi fortes
garçons alors juste une petite seconde
parce que là je vais devoir intéressant
qui se passe là je pense que anus pour
être prix
donc voilà après il y a plein d'avis et
c'est vrai que
moi j'ai eu des élèves filles qui
voulaient jouer avec les filles parce
que c'était facile
etc et j'avais d'autres filles qui
étaient hors de question déjà que les
filles j'ai eu de tout et j'ai jamais
poussé d'un côté ou de l'autre j'ai
toujours respecter un petit peu ce que
faisait les filles et ça que pour un
club
quand un défi qui peut faire un podium
facilement parce qu'elle est forte
nous en tant que club ben ça rapporte
des médailles tu vois moi je suis
dirigeant club et je j'encourage les
filles dans mon club je pète
voilà tu as tout en fait donc du coup
mais je pense que c'est plus vraiment
c'est plus vraiment
[Musique]
une question
une question un peu je pense
chaque personne est différente à chaque
personne la voix différemment mais voilà
c'est un débat c'est un débat et je sais
qu'il y a eu ce débat il y a pas très
longtemps sur la chaîne de yosha il
avait invité Mathilde Conju
qui est d'ailleurs une des meilleures
choses françaises qui a plus de 2200
[Musique]
pour parler un peu de tout ça et
d'ailleurs la vidéo maintenant d'être
sur Youtube donc si vous si vous si vous
voulez voir tout ça allez voilà la
chaîne de Yoshi et si vous êtes une
fille allez jouer avec tout le monde
parce que vous voulez mais
guéri il est en train de faire un sort
là à West les saut désolé on a un peu
perdu cette cette partie mais là il est
en train de réaliser un truc
Wesley il a pas bougé une pièce depuis
le début toutes ces pièces sont
quasiment sur les colonnes de départ et
les lignes de départ
il est monstrueux monstrueux il va
gagner la partie en fait j'ai
l'impression là où est-ce qu'il va
devoir se défendre comme un beau diable
et même tu vois il a commencé avec 7
minutes
au temps on va on va lui répondre à
l'oral désolé je j'ai vu ta question
mais j'étais en plein débat donc j'ai
pas eu le temps de de
tout répondre en fait en cas d'égalité
les joueurs datent les partager
on pourrait faire deux points d'écart
mais tu sais que ça on jouerait
peut-être toute la nuit des fois donc il
existe l'armage et donc qui permet de de
partager en une seule partie le score et
le résultat
donc là l'idée c'est vraiment de faire
une seule partie les Noirs ont 7 minutes
à la pendule contre 10 pour les blancs
donc il y a un avantage 3 minutes pour
les jours qu'elle est blanc mais en cas
de nul c'est le noir qui remporte la
partie il faut savoir que voilà c'est
déjà un bel avantage d'avoir les blancs
donc avoir les blancs plus 3 minutes
c'est un très bel avantage par contre tu
es obligé de gagner et ça c'est
difficile les noirs sont très contents
avec une partie de nulle dans cette
position on a vu tout à l'heure goût
cage par exemple le jeune indien qui
avait une position gagnante avec les
noirs et la même pas cherché elle a
gagné il a juste cherché à la stabilité
et oh là là l'ordinateur a pas aimé le
coup
il a voulu impressionner son adversaire
peut-être pas
du pion quoi
[Musique]
juste oublié café un gros pion comme ça
avec tempo sur la dame c'est énorme hein
une partie lente il y a aussi la fatigue
et puis en plus des parties lentes et
tout ça et bien ça fait quand même trois
jours qu'on est là il joue des parties
lentes puis en plus Armageddon
de jouer à ce niveau là mais après quand
même les meilleurs du monde et on s'est
rare de les voir faire des
fautes
j'aurais bien aimé sur la tête de zoo
juste pour savoir pour voir un peu
ce qui se passe mais il est clair
il est clair que c'était pas prévu cette
affaire parce qu'évidemment
le cavalier qui va juste prendre une
tour au prochain coup parce que si tu
prends la
et 4 va tomber avec les chèques
pour rester sur F5 F4
donc voilà je t'invite à aller voir la
vidéo sur la chaîne de Yoshi
la chaîne c'est la vidéo avec Mathilde
quand je sais pas comment on peut la
retrouver mais
ils ont beaucoup parlé de ce genre de
choses
là c'est un débat trop long c'est pas
compliqué pour aujourd'hui
quand c'est mort ils font ça avant de
réfléchir non si
ça va être vraiment abandon un certain
en fait il cherche une arnaque là il
cherche une arnaque si il en trouve pas
bah il va attendre la main sur son
adversaire parce qu'il va lui faire
donc il va essayer de tendre un piège
dans cette position qu'est-ce que ça
peut être pas trop parce qu'il y a pas
il y a pas d'échec
il y a rien
un truc pour donner des échecs
une fois qu'il aura tout tenté une fois
qu'il aura tout tenté
tu sais qu'en début de partie les
joueurs se servent comment ça la partie
et derrière
quand la partie se termine et ben on se
serre la main peu importe le résultat et
souvent on abandonne on dit rien on tend
la main sur l'adversaire très souvent en
fait très souvent
très souvent c'est vrai que bon à haut
niveau on se pose plus la question et
c'est vrai que à partir la fourchette
attention c'est la seule arnaque
qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur bah ouais il
veut faire nul ça suffit
avec une pièce de plus c'est un peu j'ai
envie de dire plutôt que de faire nul
avec une pièce de plus mais la règle de
l'Armageddon c'est j'ai une enfin si je
fais nul je gagne la partie
prendre la tête avec les noirs bien sûr
et donc Guy qui l'emporte comme je
l'avais prévu ça fait un point de plus
pour moi tu me dois 160 je sais plus
alors
rapidement
[Musique]
on va revenir un peu en arrière là il y
a une dame qui a disparu
il a sacré la dame contre deux tours il
a pris une tour et une deuxième tour il
a fait chaque intermédiaire pour cette
pollution elle est perdue c'est un génie
je pense
et menacer des maths un peu de partout
quel génie carwana qu'est-ce qu'il a
converti avec une grande propre
partie et on le revoit un peu revenir un
peu au meilleur niveau
et il faut ouais on se rappelle qu'il
avait fait une performance incroyable
c'était à Saint-Louis à la singfield Cup
ça devait être en 2015 je crois 14
peut-être c'est presque 10 ans déjà il
avait gagné il avait gagné 8 parties de
suivi je crois un truc un truc de fou
comme ça au plus haut niveau mondial ça
n'arrive jamais et il s'était retrouvé
2820 et l'autre deuxième joueur mondiale
il est resté très longtemps deuxième
joueur mondial et l'année dernière ça
c'est pas très bien passé pour lui il a
raté un peu ses candidats il a il a eu
l'année difficile il est reparti il est
retourné un peu dans le j'allais dans
les tréfonds non il est toujours top 5
mondial c'est là mais
en fait souvent il se rappelle au bon
souvenir de tout le monde et il leur
rappelle pourquoi voilà il est tout
simplement un jour d'élite en ce moment
il est 5e mondial
avec il a le même élo que jingle liren
quel champion
tout ce genre là ils sont tous après
même niveau pas ça se joue à pas grand
chose entre digne n'est pas
même fille ou Caruana enfin c'est c'est
même niveau quoi c'est même niveau et
pas grand chose en plus je pense surtout
la forme aussi du moment
pour tout un et là je vais roi il a joué
sur la partie entre entre notre français
à l'IRESA ferruggia
alors
venir un peu s'arrêter à cavalier
[Musique]
un dame je comprends pas
une pièce ok
bien sûr ok ok et oui bien sûr
c'est vrai j'avais oublié ce fou F5 qui
est très né encore
très très brillant assez fort
tant qu'on y est dans le dans le saccage
de dames
quelque chose ici ouais c'est hyper
chaud bon ça bien sûr les joueurs ils
l'ont vu
F5 une erreur apparemment ah ouais
apparemment c'était une erreur attends
je vais regarder ce que l'ordi aurait
préféré ouais mais c'est un trouvable
tout remis il aurait préféré tourner
pour empiler sur la colonne E c'est pas
c'est pas complètement idiot quoi oui je
suis d'accord mais bon enfin ça devient
extrêmement difficile à trouver quoi
au pire qui défendent plus je sais pas
non mais en fait ça paraît logique
maintenant que tu y penses mais bon
surtout qu'il lui reste 22 minutes il a
pas le temps de se plonger très
profondément dans toutes ces réflexions
pour ça c'est un apparemment c'était pas
le bon coup mais bon c'est hyper
difficile le roi blanc qui est qui est
faible ici 11 minutes contre 22
attention il y a encore 8 9 coups à
jouer en chaos pour obtenir le
fameux rajoutant même pas rajoute juste
un tout petit sacrément de rien du tout
qui est pas grand chose au final
donc pour CC1 mais globalement il s'en
sort très très bien
parce qu'on s'attendait au moins ce qui
se retrouve avec un pion isolé et même
pas mais il a vraiment bien mené sa
barque dans cette position et là il va
gagner sa partie c'est terminé
un truc comme ça il y a eu C4 il y a eu
tout un qui menace maths cavalier bouge
d'un F3 roi G1 abandon le cavalier est
en prise de poids c'est qu'elle bouge il
y aura Matt en E8
c'était une partie mais juste modèle
assez model
trop trop fort Fabi allez on revient sur
ça alors le cash prize
je sais pas mal
mais oui oui
il a joué mon coup de derbeek et
apparemment c'est une grosse gaffe il y
a quoi il a pris en B6 et apparemment
c'est turbo gaz d'après l'ordinateur
de plus pour les blancs mais grosse
pression sur sur
un seul coup désolé je regarde à l'ordi
fatigué mais le seul coup d'après
l'ordinateur pour tenir c'est roi j'ai
un
groupe de si je veux me défendre là j'ai
carréé G3 échec
découverte et qui me enfin découverte
tout âge qui permet
de mater comme ça enfin de manger la
tour comme ça à tout retourne et j'ai
presque envie de faire ça je sais pas si
je tomate
les deux tours bref
donc pour la pas possible et surtout
pour cela c'est pareil c'est la même
chose donc je ne peux pas en fait
l'option F2 est indéfendable
oui mais c'est bon
est obligatoire et si je prends ici la
pour calculer alors ça ça a l'air pas
mal pour les blancs parce que je vais
prendre la pièce qui défend la pièce en
F2
dans sa peur
ça a l'air chaud en tout cas
là les deux joueurs sont en train
d'essayer de ce matin comme ça qui peut
arriver aussi
et là la menace mais la cavalh3 sur sa
marche tactiquement marcher
et donc si on joue au roi je viens ici
qui va être un des seuls coups et en
plus le pire c'est que Abdou a 8 minutes
on joue encore 7 coups
et qu'il a une position très très
difficile où ils peuvent tromper
donc attention en tout cas
un autre Gilbert
3 comment arrive la catastrophe
voyons voir
comment c'est
j'ai pas envie
ouais ouais c'est l'enfer a l'air de se
déchaîner là sur
des problèmes
et dernière question est-ce qu'on peut
pas donner une cale avec les Blancs et
toujours pouvoir je vous pour la nul
dans cette pause là
je prends là et que j'arrive à manger
ici ça peut le faire quoi mais là il y a
trop de choses j'ai l'activité des
pièces il y a des raisonnements avec ton
rond F1 il y a trop de choses qui
montrent que
que tu as une position qui est trop
difficile
je pense qu'il va juste gagner en fait
pour CD1 bonne soirée à toi sinon merci
d'être là en tout cas salut Simon
Simon qui prend goût aux échecs on l'a
déjà vu hier et on sait que vous êtes
nombreux à nous regarder tous les jours
là ça il attaque la dame donc il se dit
bon
premier attaque enfin c'est la force
le rapport de force il se dit j'attaque
une pièce plus forte que ce que lui
m'attaque mais si je commence par tout
rêve de dame F2
tours
en premier
mais attends il y a pas tout internet
ouais c'est vachement
je peux pas l'enlever de la dame
et donc si je prenais ici et ben il
prenait la mienne et tu continues à
défendre vite en plus pourquoi tu
bougeras cavale ok mais ça a l'air
tactiquement gagnant pour notre ami
airesa
à la découverte
magnifique et je te dis la réfute de
c'était juste roi géant c'était juste 3
G1 sur ton F2 et ça tenait alors que là
cavale de ça va pas tenir du tout est-ce
que tu penses qu'il a vu Abdou qu'il
avait vu qu'il avait les problèmes de
c'est magnifique c'est fini en fait hein
en plus
il va attendre la main c'est fini il se
rend compte de la gravité des dégâts il
vient de se prendre une tactique de
mutant le français qui est en feu si je
prends la
voilà
la menace de la menace de cavalh 3
demeure
[Musique]
oui pour lui c'est du puzzle
que bon peut-être qu'il l'a vu et s'est
dit bon ben justement foutu que j'essaie
de de
[Musique]
juste penser à tout reprendre F2 je
pense à tout et se dire bah je fais moi
j'ai un et je mets et puis ça va
ouais et ça marche ça marche
cette histoire de roi géant surtout
reprend F2 mais alors là Caval F2 que
faire bah rien je crois que c'est juste
abandon en fait dans cette position
c'est un joli mat en plus avec sacrifice
de dames
il y avait perdu la première partie
passe à
[Musique]
Google
avait battu à l'IRESA alors de la
première partie il me semble là c'est
pas de bêtises
tout à fait et à lireza c'est refait
avec les blancs sur ma médias avec une
partie folle elle a encore une fois il
va battre sur une partie encore une fois
folle
elle est très très belle et les raisins
qui est en grande forme
qui joue le lien mais tout le temps
blanc noir blanc noir il joue pour
gagner et ça c'est beau et je pense que
la cadence elle nous a fait du bien sur
cette game parce que là tu vois ce genre
de maths magnifique on voit quand même
jamais en partie longue ça va jamais
jusque là
aide un petit peu à des
erreurs tout ça tu vois
permet de choses hier Abdou il avait une
partie qui était
totalement perdante contre Ariane Paris
il a réussi à retourner la situation
[Musique]
il va essayer de tenir et c'est pas mal
ce qui fait hein
[Musique]
et maintenant je te prends et après ça
change quoi bah après je te prends à 5
quoi
je peux pas échec et dame là et j'ai
l'impression que je maquille
ouais
bien sûr
que c'est pas si clair cette finale elle
peut être dure à tenir parce que
imaginons je mets une tour en F3
et j'attends
tu veux faire une forteresse c'est ça
et là ça n'existe pas c'est Magnus qui
l'a dit non mais ça marcher
[Musique]
en pratique d'ailleurs à livraison qui
avait
je crois que c'était contre le dépôt
il avait
démonté la forteresse de nepoméhatchi
est-ce qu'il va prendre à 5
ça m'est déjà arrivé en partie de
prendre une de prendre une de mes pièces
non attends j'ai pris
la pièce de mon adversaire avec une de
ses pièces ah oui c'est pas mal ça
j'ai gagné quand même ce jour-là mais
j'étais un peu fatigué
en fait alors non il a vu il a vu il m'a
fait remarquer quand même
donc j'ai repris mon coup j'ai été faire
plein pour sur ce coup-là bon désolé
j'ai essayé j'aurais essayé
la position celle là slity
[Musique]
ils viennent de jouer 40 40 coups donc
c'est à dire que maintenant ils ont un
incrément de 10 secondes par contre il y
a 4 minutes plus 10 secondes par coup
pour pour Abdou
il a 17 minutes il peut encore se
prendre un bon gros moment pour
réfléchir et il a pas l'air d'en avoir
besoin parce que là il est en train de
jouer les coups tempo il sait très bien
comment gagner ça c'est une finale
gagnante tout simplement c'est gagnant
est-ce qu'on a assuré pas encore à 100%
mais
pas loin quand même on est assez rassuré
quand même
pas cette partie à lire ça
tome 3 3 et fin un seul coup pour
empêcher ça ça serait difficile
peut-être pour défendre ceux qui ont un
enfant
peut commencer à pousser des pions de
l'endroit
pour créer des réseaux parce que des
pièces blanches peuvent pas trop bouger
tu vois le cavalière sort jamais enfin
il ressorti par via B2 mais ça fait déjà
un coup de plus maintenant
[Musique]
en réseau et jouer avec une dame contre
un cavalier qui ne joue pas aussi et en
plus
mais ça devrait gagner mais ça c'est
quand même là à dire ça qui a 15 buts à
la pendule avec du temps de partout
contre 4 donc
toutes les pièces adverses
un peu B2 parce qu'il a prévu un truc
sympa
maintenant que le roi est en F1 tu vois
mal placé
il est plus sujet à se prendre des
échecs une fois en F1
est un peu mal placé maintenant le
réseau dans les courants
c'est pas vraiment que c'est long c'est
pas long c'est juste trop tard c'est
c'est
F4 Caval C4 juste tu recules le la dame
ouais
mais non mais ça ça va gagner il y a eu
qui avait les béliers c'est la partie
ces trois
je prends la
et bon je peux rien
essayer de trouver une
forteresse alors une forteresse d'échec
c'est une position dans laquelle j'ai
moins d'avantages que toi alors là par
exemple je suis j'ai une dame pour
cavalier mais si jamais j'arrive à
trouver un setup où les Noirs n'arrivent
plus à progresser et ben je peux je peux
tenir la gueule
il espère trouver une situation où les
Noirs ne peuvent plus avancer c'est très
très peu probable mais tant que c'est
probable en fait il va jouer bah oui la
raison continue
des parties et trouver des solutions
même si on n'a pas tu essayes et c'est
pas en abandonnant une partie que tu vas
gagner
donc il va il se bat elle est perdue
mais à part ça en face bon c'est c'est
qui roule il est extrêmement fort mais
bon bah il peut toujours se tromper
voilà par cavale pas grand chose mais au
moins il a activé sa pièce très mauvaise
en quatre
les deux maintenant la tour ok tu peux
l'activer si tu veux en D8 je vais
simplement bloquer mon roi en fait c'est
un gros problème de coordination
c'est les blancs il y a trois qui est
dans les courants d'air il y a la tour
là
et
le problème c'est que c'est compliqué je
pense que si le purin qui n'était pas là
peut-être c'est nul tu vois
genre je fais ça ça
et en fait je fais retour là et pour la
revenir pour la revenir
dépendu par le pion tout le monde se
défend
pas
je peux pas faire la même chose parce
qu'il y aura des réseaux avec le passé
tu vois mais c'est vrai que si le plus
n'était pas là il y a peut-être des
chances de
peut-être des chances de même sur
l'option F j'ai l'impression qu'il
poussait du pionger jusqu'en G3
mais je mange à chaque fois oui dans
peut-être tu as raison mais je pense que
il y a moyen
à un moment donné
[Musique]
il y avait des rêves de forteresse
clairement là il sont en train de
s'évaporer depuis A4 que nos cultures
donc il donne un pion en fait de facto
mais on a même pas envie de prendre en
fait peut-être que ce pion
va permettre aux blancs
c'est ça exactement
[Musique]
VF4
il
va pas prendre pas prendre deux fois
à mon avis pour lui il y a pas de
différence de difficulté entre cette
position c'est la même c'est plus ou
moins la même chose quoi
ça je l'ai mangé c'est à moi et
maintenant là j'ai cinq
et on monte un petit peu le roi on
pousse comme ça
moi je veux bien un petit G5 ici je vais
mais
mon plan ça va devenir 4 à un moment
donné
et d'essayer de G4
mais pour ça j'aimerais bien voir
g73f6 pas de fourchette c'est bon et en
fait même sur Wi-Fi la menace ça devient
ça devient dame B5
qui est échange tout en 3 et 5 et tu
gagnes la finale depuis aussi
dans ce cavalier va devoir rebouger
cette case n'est pas sûr pour lui et
elle va sûrement se caler en F3 c'est
tout l'objectif de la
tout l'objectif de
la forteresse
[Musique]
j'ai envie avant de faire G4
imagine si elle est résa pour une raison
X ou Y ne parvient pas à gagner cette
finale et se fait emmener en Armageddon
imagine la tronche qui va tirer pour la
pendant la mer
oui si tu es une passage tu fais
l'Armageddon on est capable de faire
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
la conversion davantage d'aller résa qui
a obtenu cette superbe finale avec un
pion de plus et dame contre tour et
cavalier contre nos diabète et qui
entraîne la convertir à ses propres
mains
ouais ça a l'air très très bien pour les
blancs pour les noirs
sont pas si dur c'est pas lui de
chercher bien lui il va juste faire des
coups pour attendre ah c'est pas très
dur mais il en a pas plus il en a pas
trop non plus
que ça va ça va
c'est pas lui qui va réfléchir
mais bon c'est l'ordinateur tu sais
attention à cette fameuse forteresse on
en parle depuis tout à l'heure
même si ça existe pas ça serait dommage
de s'en prendre une
ouais c'est vrai que du scarsen qui
avait dit ça son interview je ne crois
pas au forteresse après avoir
gagné une finale de plus de 100 coups
contre Topaloff je crois
c'était assez ça manquait pas de panache
après il y a des forteresses qui sont
contents
[Musique]
ouais c'est ça il dit je le croirais
quand je le verrai quoi peut-être mais
celle-là ça se voit j'ai une dame pion
pour tout cavalier
G4 qui vient bloquer tu vois la limite
si je pouvais jouer par exemple j'ai 4
nesprit mon cavalier ici par exemple
et peut-être que là je pourrais espérer
bloquer la police
mais sinon leur dire en train de
détester les coups de les raisins moi
j'aurais fait exactement pareil pour
l'instant bah moi aussi mais bon
ça paraît logique
tu ramènes
mais j'ai oublié qu'il y a juste d'armes
prend aussi c'est apprendre
à parler de toi sur
[Musique]
sur sur le Steam je crois que c'était
slity je crois qu'il
nous demandait
si il y a pas très longtemps
je me souviens c'était fou au caille je
crois ouais
on avait parlé toutes sortes de thèmes
ouais en fait on parlait du du fait en
fait pourquoi il y a pas de femme qui
joue l'échecs etc
le bon vieux débat que qu'on connaît
bien et
donc je les ai envoyé vers ta chaîne
j'ai vu que tu avais fait une super
vidéo avec Mathilde de Conju à ce sujet
là et du coup je t'ai envoyé sur ta
chaîne voir un petit peu le le grand
débat et
[Musique]
etc donc voilà
qui peuvent arriver mais là j'ai quand
même du mal à y croire je pense que les
blancs en fait manquent de stabilité
avec leurs pièces
et j'ai du mal à croire à la forteresse
ici c'est ça il va être dur de les
placer sur des cases où elles se protège
tout entre elles surtout depuis qu'il a
fait G4
que prise ce serait pas une bonne idée
là il faut pousser F4
[Musique]
depuis qu'il a laissé les champs jamais
changé en ouais attention à Blue qui a
quand même très peu de temps attendu et
moi
il y a des chances attention que en
finale forteresse tout ça il y a pas
mieux F400
[Musique]
que je voulais avant
donc
c'est pas simple à passer alors H5
peut-être
ou c'est un peu tout match
pour l'instant Dame des six se replace
un peu rêve 2
j'aime bien H5 à chaque fois
mais après attention moi j'ai toi aussi
moi j'espion ça y est il y a des chances
de de nul aussi donc pas trop trop
échanger non plus tu as fini par te
prendre tout réussi tout et tu perds la
partie ah oui non mais ouais
incroyable
on peut juste pris comme ça moi tu es
sûr qu'il y a pas de toi
c'est vraiment pas si simple
je la voyais tellement plus simple tout
à l'heure quand il y avait des pions les
deux côtés parce que
encore et là il vient de de donner la
dame un peu parce que il y a pas le
choix et il faut encore le battre quoi
à quel point les joueurs ont des
ressources tout le temps tu vois Abdou
pour le battre trois fois
il y aura jamais mieux que roi ouais
c'est vrai c'est possible qu'à la fin
par exemple un truc comme ça et puis
finalement cavalier enfin ça a changé
cavalez-vous mais il y aura
contre retour c'est gagnant c'est
gagnant toriquement mais je ne vous
dirai pas que je ne l'ai pas gagné il
faut
à Barcelone
j'ai joué un
random et j'avais dame contre toi et
j'ai pas gagné
mais 50 coups
de ma gueule
et contre morose et Beach
mais c'est pas si simple encore parce
que l'ordator il a gagné trop facilement
parce que bon c'est le calcul en fait
[Musique]
je l'ai gagné
beaucoup plus dur que ce que j'avais
imaginé
souvent la position gagnante c'est une
tactique de 10 coups
avec plein d'échecs un peu de partout
c'est un cauchemar donc un humain
la défense c'est dur de défendre mais en
plus je connaissais un petit peu j'ai
essayé de mettre mon roi en diagonal de
la tour pour essayer de mais après j'ai
dû rater plein de trucs probablement
mais bon après Barcelone c'est encore un
peu spécial qui connaît ce tournoi
il sera rarement
effray pour l'échecs
géant un forteresse enfin qui n'existe
pas bien sûr
quand même mais je sais pas dans quelles
conditions
et pourquoi elle est raisable ils sont
rangés cette parce que oui
[Musique]
c'est peut-être plus simple
par exemple tu vois donc s'il était venu
en G6 j'aurais fait ça et H5 n'est pas
possible parce que je fais échec échec
est nul parce que maintenant j'ai ma
forteresse
G4 non ouais alors attends
voilà mais
je reviens ok non j'allais dire échange
massif en gs5 maintenant si on regarde
juste le pion h tu vas récupérer en fait
ça va pas tenir quand même
mais bon
on va jouer la finale dans la fameuse
[Musique]
des deux
bras blanc en plus c'est déjà dans le
coin donc ça va être ça va être encore
encore
c'est sûr
c'est très dur après les joueurs en
défense on a vu comment il est encore
tout droit sur sa chaise tout ça
franchement
il est au combat il est clairement un
combat il va se battre il va essayer de
trouver le meilleur défense
même si la position est extrêmement
difficile lui il a mis le cavalan E1 sur
la ligne qu'on regardait là
oui
merci
puis cette prophétie ne passerez parce
que bon ça serait bizarre ok il a poussé
et maintenant on passe en passant H4
on récupère la mie cavalier
ça commence à sentir ça va commencer à
partir en eau de boudin à G4 là et après
apparemment là j'ai mis l'ordi j'en ai
pas marre
en 52 coups ah bah oui mais tu le vois
pas Yoha regarde
c'est un coup c'est un coup qui te
ressemble
et en fait le cavalier il a l'air con
hein il peut pas empêcher de pas
empêcher la dame
et
maintenant 52 c'était vu évidemment dans
la cabine
mais maintenant 52 coups et le pire
c'est magnifique
ça fait nul j'avoue donc en fait
t'imagines l'ordi il a gagné pas
l'ordinateur
je bouge des pions encore donc ça marche
2 elle est belle elle est belle je joue
là et abandon direct
c'est joli franchement ah c'était
magnifique je pense que la case du match
c'est la case 2 parce que cette partie
il y a eu pas mal de choses qui sont pas
sur F2 il y a eu le cavalier.f.2 qui est
très jolie regardez un petit peu le
cavalier enfin le le cavalier.f.2 qui a
eu
je remonte un petit peu ici regardez
pour CD1 et ben on a eu ici les très
joli cavaliers prend F2 de la part de
firou et surtout reprendre les 7 avec
cavaler prend H3 Matt à la découverte
c'est pas encore mal attends il y a
encore des tours F2 mais
donc très joli et après cavaler ça s'est
terminé comme ça il y a eu d'un point et
la tour qui mange la dame sur F2 et puis
à la fin de la partie la dame qui vient
se donner en F2 pour faire une promotion
imparable donc c'est au foot on peut
souvent donner l'homme du match et ben
moi je donne la casse du match c'est
c'est la case 2 clairement là vendu
ouais
en tout cas on a eu de très très beau
très belle partie aujourd'hui une super
résultats va vous montrer un petit peu
un petit un petit calculatrice de tout
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui alors les
résultats c'est ça on a Hikaru qui
marque un point contre un point et demi
contre karathon ça veut dire qu'il y a
eu match nul dans la partie classique et
que Magnus a gagné l'Armageddon
ensuite bon on vient de voir on vient de
la fixer à la deuxième victoire
en particulier
qui est monstrueux depuis maintenant
plusieurs années il est en train de
monter en puissance c'est le joueur qui
a une quasiment tout le tournoi qui joue
et champion du monde d'ailleurs 2021 je
crois rapide donc c'est quand même un
sacrée perf autre montée en puissance
c'est Fabiano carruana là qui revient
top top niveau aujourd'hui il a laissé
aucune chance à Ryan tari c'est
magnifique ce qu'il a fait il a
domination positionné totale il a c'est
un pion isolé chez son adversaire et
puis il a gagné et ses trois points
mérités pour le numéro américain
monstrueux grosse partie franchement une
partie a montré à montrer en cours
d'échec
ensuite on a eu ben
la belle victoire de mon petit poulain
Gou Kech en armage et donc une partie
complètement poilue
entre mamedia rhum et goes qui a tout
envoyé comme un gros bourrin sur le roi
de Liège le roi qui a fait le tour de
l'échiquier plusieurs fois et au final
et ben les deux rois étaient maths j'ai
l'impression qu'avec ma média Rohff on
va avoir le droit en Armageddon à ça
toute la semaine c'est toujours un régal
de le voir entre Wesley sceaux et à Nice
Guiri bon j'avais un peu annoncé ça a
fait le pas rapide ils ont quand même
ils sont quand même battus mais ça fait
nul sans trop de soucis et Annie Jerry a
délivré le super performance Wesley il
est pas Armageddon là il a du mal il a
dit hier à changer la cadence à passer
de l'an à rapides donc ça fait sa
deuxième défaite de suite en Armageddon
Wesley
était bizarre parce que guéri a donné un
pion en un coup et de quoi après il a
fait une fourchette en un coup face
c'était vraiment un niveau un niveau
tout fesque c'était très bizarre donc
voilà donc les résultats alors tiens je
te laisse en parler un petit peu pendant
que je balance la la prédiction de you
make fever
ça serait bien que notre concours de
pronostics tout on est où il me semble
que j'ai gagné là je vais regarder alors
je n'ai pas du tout donc Fabiano
firou moi j'avais dit ouais alors j'ai
payé des points
au lieu des résultats quinte saine je
l'avais mis nul j'avais mis Carlson
tu avais mis nul donc tu as perdu aussi
[Musique]
let's go voilà donc petit résumé du
classement c'est Fabiano Caruana qui
domine ce tournoi va falloir aller le
chercher celui-là Fabienne et puis on va
parler aussi des rondes de demain demain
Fabiano il aura les deux noirs
après demain donc il sera opposé après
le repos tout simplement au deuxième
allez les affirmes déjà notre côté car
encore réalisé une partie de dingue
aujourd'hui il a battu ma média RH hier
il a battu nos diabète Abdou Sator off
aujourd'hui peut-être Fabiano
après-demain on sait pas on peut le
souhaiter Nakamura est dans le cou caché
dans le cou
je pense que le tournoi va être
incroyable puisque vous en tout cas en
tout cas on passe un sacré moment votre
présence tout ça pour cet événement
c'est super moi j'adore cette cadence
j'adore le tournoi et c'est vraiment ce
qu'ils sont un sac accéléré et on va
vraiment beaucoup de parties décisives
donc je suis vraiment hyper content en
tout cas de pouvoir
commenter cet événement et donc on se
revoit à partir de samedi à 17h
demain c'est repos pour les joueurs donc
pour nous aussi du coup donc moi je vous
dis
passer un bon vendredi je vous dis à
samedi merci beaucoup Antoine pour voir
accompagner pendant ces trois jours je
crois que tu reviens plus après il me
semble moi je termine là dessus donc je
vous souhaite à tous une très bonne fin
de tournoi et à la prochaine sur
chaise.com FR merci en tout cas d'avoir
commenté 3 jours avec moi et moi je vous
dis à très bientôt et puis bah écoutez
passez un bon vendredi et une bonne
soirée à bientôt Ciao